Are we live?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
For Reals Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
I'm going to stumble and fuck.
You know that when I,
when I start these things off I,
it's almost like maybe I should pretend to do a podcast for like 10 minutes
before I do a podcast just to warm my fucking stupid face up.
Well,
it's also the freshness of just coming off of be getting stone to where like she
wasn't yet.
The world is listening.
Jesus,
Brian
back to us.
We don't work for ESPN.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Prague.
Imagine if we did.
Yeah,
I was listening to that man that Josh grows.
That was interesting.
Yeah.
You can't panicked.
That's weird.
Hanging out with people that can,
cause we're so used to hanging out with comics and hanging out with somebody
that has to be like,
oh,
I can't smoke something because I don't want to get him fired.
Well,
not only that,
he's a writer.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Do you want the writers to suck?
Yeah.
Like you don't want it.
The writers of smoke weed.
Are you crazy?
What you do not want.
Colorful pros.
Do you not want,
you know,
a an imaginative piece?
Do you not want something that engages you and captures your imagination and
lets you think,
wow,
this guy is coming from a very unique point of view instead of the same tired,
old,
stupid shit.
Listen to ESPN.
Let your people have some flavor.
Yeah,
it's like Disney and not letting their artists eat mushrooms.
Well,
I bet they also wouldn't.
If I had a thing with ESPN.
I bet they wouldn't let me be sponsored by the flashlight.
I,
but that's an issue.
I bet that's an issue with people.
It's athletic.
It is.
That's true.
It's not like it does.
It does.
It itself,
it's,
it's technology applied to something that people are scared of.
Exactly.
Skewed touch that a PP scared of people knowing that you masturbate of people
knowing that you give yourself pleasure.
Ha ha ha.
Anyway,
if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy format.
We are also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech,
sport,
new mood,
and the man who started all this bullshit is here.
Used to be.
Chris knows some shit went down in the jungle.
How many people can say that?
What's your name?
Well,
most people know me as Chris and my name is Aubrey because some shit went down
to the junkers.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's a good one and we're going to get involved with all that stuff.
We've got a lot to talk about.
Aubrey and I are going to restructure the,
the the earth today.
We've decided we were going to figure out a better way to run this.
You dirty little fuckers anyway.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the Alpha brain link and throwing the code name,
Rogan.
You will get 10% off or don't.
All right.
I'm tired of you.
Whiny little Internet twats don't have to buy the vitamins.
You don't have to enjoy,
you don't have to be healthy.
You can smoke cigarettes,
you could drink whiskey,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
But if you're interested in the subject of Nootropics,
I suggest that you go online and do some research.
It's a very interesting topic and there's a lot of evidence to support the idea
that are certain nutrients
that enhance the way your brain works.
You know there are days,
we all know this where we don't feel,
you don't feel clear,
you feel like shit,
you feel cloudy.
What is that folks?
What,
what,
what gentle balance is off when you're,
when you're having off days and can that be enhanced with nutrition?
I believe at Kent and if you are interested in,
I encourage you to just go look up the subject before you buy anything.
Read some of the things that had been written and you know,
draw your own conclusions,
be objective about it.
I also suggested if you'd think that our stuff is too expensive to just copy the
ingredients,
man,
just go online,
buy your shit and bulk copy it.
Good luck to you.
I swear to God we're not that greedy.
The proof that we're not that greedy is if you don't like it is a hundred
percent money back guarantee.
Who the fuck else does that?
Yeah,
it's true.
And you can't do it any cleaner.
Okay.
I know you don't.
If you don't believe in vitamins,
you say you piss them all out.
That's all good dude.
You know,
I,
I know from personal experience,
from actual health issues that vitamins have a key benefit and your wellbeing
hundred percent your health and wellbeing are affected by vitamins.
I don't care if you see,
you know,
the bullshit about,
studies that disproves study's approved.
I don't think you can accurately get an assessment about that unless we get into
some really fucking much more detailed tests of diet and exercise and you know,
and,
and test people that aren't doing it and test people that aren't and then draw
your conclusions.
But I think vitamins enhance.
I absolutely feel like they enhance so bar shit or not,
whatever,
whatever.
We got a lot of shit to talk about.
Cue The music,
Brian.
All right.
[inaudible]
coolest moment of my life as a professional broadcaster.
What's that Ufo sound,
Brian,
when you try and do us,
I don't know how to stop that thing.
What is it?
Oh go.
After awhile it was some special effects that I was doing early on.
The outro,
Brian,
it's not going away now.
It's just in your head.
No,
come on Brian.
You got to shut that off.
Do you really not know how to shut that off?
It's gone.
This is lizards like last until a slow beat and I was going to drive me crazy
cause I'm going to hear a beat every like 30 seconds.
I want to hear it in the background.
Well,
a little constant distraction.
That's not a good sound effect.
Let's not use that one again.
I love that freaking everybody out,
man.
There's a lot of people that that they listened to this podcast man and they're
on some shit.
Okay.
The hardest freaking out with fucking alien noises.
Did you see that?
A spaceship that there's,
it's been though.
It was unlike a,
I believe it was end gadget and or Gizmodo,
one of those a gadget websites where they were talking about a,
there's all these photos of this crazy spacecraft at the government was driving
on the back of a truck and it was,
yeah it was like through Kansas.
We who knows what the fuck it was.
It could have been a weather balloon.
They're all weather balloons.
Right.
But they known that word.
We're using drones now cause the guy was arrested,
a guy who was a cattle dispute and I mean the only way this even makes sense is
that someone,
no I must have insane money and hate this guy cause the story doesn't make any
sense.
But they used a drone to determine that there was cows in this guy's property
that weren't his and that he did not alert the other.
The other,
you know,
ranch that their cattle had wandered onto his and they used a drone to determine
this.
And I'm like Jesus Christ,
how does
other guy get that drove,
find out who that guy is and follow him.
Being the guy who can call someone and say,
Hey,
yeah,
I'm having a cow problem,
my asshole neighbor,
can I borrow one of those fucking drones?
Can I borrow one of those Predator things and search around this asshole's
property?
Holy Shit Man.
They sound like a crazy violation.
And the only thing that could catch on him was that some cows had wandered over
to his property.
What the fuck man?
How many cows worth of money does it cost to hire a drone?
Yeah.
Was like an episode of American Dad.
You know what I mean?
Like using his power.
Like I just take my drone over there.
That's exactly what it sounds like.
It sounds like south park or something.
Yeah,
it's fucking completely ridiculous.
they caught the guy.
I should look up the,
the actual full story.
Drone use cattle case is that,
did you know Seth Mcfarlane's up for a grammy?
He's against like Barbara Streisand right now because he has a music CD now.
What?
Like he's,
I don't know,
it's like a seed,
like a singer.
Cattle Rustling family.
Maybe my,
my take on is wrong because they're addressing them.
And as a cattle rustling family.
So they're saying that these people were stealing Cadillac.
Jess armed with a search warrant that Nelson County Sheriff Keith Janky went
looking for six missing cows.
Wow.
Really?
That's it.
Six cows.
You use a fucking drone to find six cows.
Wow.
This is creepy.
That's American data.
Big.
There's some old laws,
horse stealing and cattle.
Super Harsh.
Like the decisions are made,
but they're just,
this is like the first like instances of this,
right?
Is this something that like the Patriot Act allows for?
It must be
right.
I think drones,
yeah.
And I'm not kidding Tam.
How else are we going to get fucked?
Are going have drones following us?
Or
even worse?
The Nda that just passed the,
the National Defense Authorization Act,
that's really scary because it allows them to,
uh,
treat the United States as a battlefield and that means that they can stop
things with troops.
Like they're going to use our military against American citizens.
It's like a war against the people.
It was civil war.
I'm like,
it's really completely insane.
And the indefinite detention.
The fact that you don't have to have a warrant.
They,
if they think you're a threat,
they can just attain you indefinitely.
You know when you see John Mccain out there like supporting that,
you're like,
wow man,
you don't see where this is going to go.
You really
think that that should be allowed.
You start to put the pieces of the puzzle together.
Obama,
you know,
authorizing 20,000 extra troops here for the domestic front.
I think you sent a tweet out about that,
so scared to put the pieces together.
It looks like they know some shit's going to go down and they're preparing for
the instance in which it does,
which is,
which is scary.
It looks like the only way this would be getting past the only way this would be
accepted by so many people and not enrage others is that they know there's going
to be a massive civil unrest.
They know there's going to be something nutty.
Yeah,
you get that.
You got that feeling for sure.
Although that's terrifying.
It is terrifying.
But I,
as I thought about it too,
I mean back in the days where you crushed rebellions,
you know,
there's plenty of tyrannies that have crushed rebellions throughout history.
There was always certain factors present.
There was a lack of information able to circulate.
They would close down those things.
The governments hinting at different ways of trying to do that,
but I don't think they'll ever be successful.
The Internet's too prevalent.
It's too powerful,
as you've said.
You know,
they'll build ways around it.
they'll find ways to communicate.
And then also,
you know,
the people they were suppressing,
we're generally not as well armed as the people who are trying to suppress them.
So they had an overwhelming,
you know,
force mature of technological superiority in their arms.
But this is a well armed nation and I just can't imagine that even our troops,
the,
some that are brainwashed or not,
whatever,
really want to take out their real guns against our citizens.
But the citizens when pushed hard enough,
you know,
we're all,
we're all armed.
I mean at a certain point where you know,
they're abusing our people grandly and it could get really bad and I just can't
imagine that it could get to that level.
I can't imagine that it can either,
but it really seems like they're preparing for it.
And when you see how things have slid in certain parts of this country,
how far things have gone.
Like if you ever see like any of the documentaries on Detroit,
well they show you like how bad it is.
They're now 47% illiteracy rate.
I mean the functional literacy rate,
47% that's half the people can't read.
And that's incredible.
And these houses that are,
you know,
up for sale for like $1,000 you know,
a $500 just abandoned building after abandoned building.
It's like wow.
Like we know in our lifetime that this is all changed.
We know,
we know it's possible for things to go horribly wrong.
Completely fall apart.
Yeah,
I I,
I agree.
I just think that final step that they're trying to prepare for as a step that's
ultimately destined for failure.
Like they won't be able to pull that trigger.
It's kind of like in a nuclear,
in the nuclear age,
you know,
there's a certain level of warfare that you just can't do.
You know,
like you can't get massive group of people and attack another country that has a
nuclear armament because they'll just use the nuke.
Like you can't push the Americans too hard cause we're all fucking armed,
you know,
and we're all going to be able to communicate with each other.
Like there's a certain boundary point where it's destined to fail.
So I think they have a weird strategy.
It's like they're preparing for something but the end game can't work.
Like they can't push that final button where they put live rounds in the troops
and start us.
Like
we just will not fucking allow that under any circumstance.
And that's what the founders and creating the second amendment I believe they
had in mind was not to protect against their enemies but also against our own
government.
Misusing the power of the army.
It's funny how few people are willing to engage that idea,
you know,
willing to even even throw it out there that it's possible that there could be
some sort of a massive civil war in this country and then literally we might
have troops,
American troops fighting against Americans that nobody wants to think that.
Nobody wants to think that that's possible.
You know?
That's why I wouldn't,
you know,
they,
they talk about the second amendment,
you know,
allowing for an armed militia.
Right.
Isn't that like they are the well regulated militia.
Yeah.
Something like that.
And people go,
what do you know what your rise against the government,
just 10 years ago that sounded like nonsense.
That sounded like the stupidest thing in the world.
Like why the fuck would you do that?
This is the greatest country on earth.
But within the 10 years,
since nine 11 the deterioration of what this country stood for to me and to I
think a lot of us,
it's just,
it's been shit on.
Yeah.
It's been,
it's been used.
It's just like,
like what we're supposed,
like one of the reasons why everybody was so horrified after nine 11 it's like,
you know,
people who don't pay that much attention to foreign politics,
they don't know exactly what all the complaints are and what,
what countries were occupying,
what's sacred land where,
you know,
we have fucking troops marching on every day if they don't understand like what,
what the,
the actual reason for someone being pissed off at us for their view of the,
the United States,
most likely.
It's like really pretty rosy.
Like were there like the peacekeepers are the world and yeah,
Vietnam was a little shady,
but we did fuck up Hitler.
Okay.
And Japan was ready to take over.
We took care of that nonsense to the Russia.
We bankrupt them bitches.
All right,
we're good.
We got this.
But you,
you dig deeper and you pay more attention to it and you go look at what could
happen in 10 years.
Look how it can just slide away from you in 10 years.
Things like the Patriot Act,
things like tapping into people's fucking cell phones on a regular basis with no
warrants.
And the fact that the Patriot Act was only used a handful of times for actual
terrorist attacks,
but was used hundreds and thousands of times for drugs.
Hundreds and thousands of times.
I forget the real number,
but it was just a ridiculous disproportionate number were the majority of the
Times they use the Patriot Act was for drugs.
That's what people,
yeah,
I mean if you allow that power,
it's going to be used in whatever means possible.
That's why,
you know,
preventing these things like that act that just passed is so vital because you
give a law,
you know,
you let a lot pass with one intention.
Well,
it doesn't really matter what the intentions are.
Even the people trying to pass a may have those intentions,
but ultimately with that power enabled,
the corruption is inevitable and it happens extremely fast and that's even a
benevolent kind of view.
The other view is,
yeah,
we'll get it passed under these auspices and then we'll really use it to,
you know,
to do whatever their other men,
their means are so set up that they have now where the,
they're allowed to like come up with laws and then these few handful of
motherfuckers that have gotten to the cool kids party,
they get to vote on everything that it goes through the Senate and it goes
through Congress and they agreed to it.
And then if the president doesn't veto it,
that's it.
It went through this,
you know,
x amount of people,
300 million people are changed now and affected by this corrupt stupid fucking
shit bag unconstitutional idea that these fuckheads past and it's just somehow
or another they're allowed to do that.
That's a red [inaudible] form of government.
I mean,
that's ridiculous.
I don't care.
I mean,
you know,
representative or not,
that's stupid.
That's a terrible way for really important shit to get introduced into our
culture.
You know,
and the fact that that is the way the system is set up,
it's like ultimately the whole thing needs to be like radically overhauled.
It's not like a little minor tweak.
It needs to be radically overhauled because there's so much that gets done and
so much that sucks out there.
That's just be just,
we just follow it because it's written somewhere and because everybody agreed to
it at one point in time.
But as we've gotten older and you know,
you get a much better grasp on how fucked up the world really is and how
ridiculous some of the laws that are in place and what the actual origin of
those laws are and if the fact that they're actually based in real clear and
measurable corruption and you know,
it should be like a fuck load of people should be in jail is what it should be,
you know?
But instead it just kind of like it is the law.
It's the way it is.
It's on the paper.
I think there's,
you know,
there's two ways to approach it.
And I think one of the interesting things that we're going to do is,
uh,
you know,
there's two problems.
One is what's wrong with,
you know,
the currently the society that we're in and how to bridge that gap.
But I think as important as anything is to just start fresh,
take away all that momentum,
all of those,
you know,
different people trained in the different ways what you expect and just kind of
start from scratch and say if you could start from scratch,
you know,
how could you set this up?
Knowing what we know now and knowing the different pathways that history of
already paid,
how do you prevent these disasters?
How do you prevent this corruption?
How do you create a model that will create momentum going the other way?
And then the question just becomes how do you bridge these two situations?
Is it possible?
Is it possible to go from our current situation to the ideal situation?
If so,
how?
And then,
and then kind of fill that in with the real issue is financial.
Like,
what do you do with all the money?
Do you divvy it up?
What do you do?
You know?
And there's a lot of people out there that are at zero right now that would love
that they would love,
like everybody gets a fair shake,
man.
Everybody gets a fear piece,
which is not supposed to be how it is.
Everybody has the opportunity to go out and make money by whatever means you
want to do it.
And if your means or unsuccessful,
it doesn't mean the system sucks.
It means that for whatever reason,
whether you're in a saturated environment or whether you know the,
the job that you want is highly,
highly touted and it's one that everybody wants to get.
And there's a lot of competition.
Is that what it is?
What is the reason?
Ultimately you're not able to do what you're doing,
you know?
Because it's gotta be a reason for it.
Yes.
The situation we're currently in economically sucks,
but I think a lot of these dudes are just willing to lay down.
A lot of these dudes are willing to go,
it's rigged.
Thing is rigged,
man.
I can't,
they're not even willing to try to figure out some way through it.
We all know that at the beginning of you what I mean,
I'm sure you must've felt this a points in your life and I certainly felt it as
a a struggling comedian.
There's point points where you know,
you feel like you're not going to make it.
You know,
you feel like this is ridiculous pursuit.
I'm going to,
I'm a fucking failure,
you know,
this is,
and if,
if,
if I,
if I was doing that and then I thought if I had these like self defeating
thoughts and then I thought that the system was rigged.
Like if I was,
you know,
going to college to get some sort of a job in business,
then I realized this system is rigged.
And now I'm,
I mean that's self defeating stage and then I'm marching around.
That might not necessarily be the best move for you.
Yeah,
no,
that's gonna that's gonna cause an end to this situation prematurely.
Sure.
People recognize that about any big giant movement is that they're not entirely
pure.
Oh sure.
You know,
like there's a lot of people that are in this occupy movement that make a lot of
fucking sense.
There's a lot of people that are saying a lot of really important shit and then
there's a lot of crazy assholes pee themselves.
Exactly.
I read,
I read an interesting piece on that and there is a Dutch economist,
I think it's got a Haber mass and uh,
his point was that they're leading this almost anarchist movement without any
set defined principles as a form of kind of awareness for self correction by the
majority basically saying that there's nothing that they can say,
no bill,
no law,
no rule that will be respected enough to actually come out and say do this
because the whole system is so corrupt and nepotistic and circular that somehow,
you know,
they would get that concession and then it would be over.
But by creating this kind of anarchist state where they're just in certain areas
and they're just there,
they're causing people like us to be more aware,
to heighten that sense of self awareness and self critical side side of things
and may actually affect the majority to change and a much broader level than if
they actually had demands and actually started to do it.
So yeah,
I mean you can criticize the people.
I mean I think I've said it before,
playing hacky sack out on the Austin City Hall,
you know,
it's not exactly going to inspire the most amount of people,
but it is going to cause people to talk about it and cause you know,
room for self reflection.
And I think that kind of anarchist protest almost,
which one it is,
is,
is effective in that way.
Yeah.
I think it definitely gets an energy out there and that energy is most certainly
interpreted with no question whatsoever.
And everybody's mad,
this is not good.
We're not happy.
And we were so unhappy that we're going to camp out in tents.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really kind of ridiculous.
I mean,
and then it didn't.
Then it has to be,
do we unite with these people and try to bring them all back or
is it us against them and when it becomes us against them and then they start
preparing for us against them with like this NDA passage,
you know,
that's what it sounds like to me.
It sounds like they're preparing for some sort of a,
almost a military style,
civil unrest in this country.
Well,
the pain is on,
they just minor at this point.
Really nothing.
Look what's going on in Egypt,
man.
Yeah.
Did you see some of these,
uh,
these beatings in Egypt,
they are beating the fuck out of these protesters,
man.
I mean,
beat him to death.
It's horrendous man.
Horrendous Shit.
It's really,
really hard to watch these people running on the street.
There are hundreds of them and they encounter like one or two protesters and
just club the fuck out of them while they're unconscious.
They're jumping on them and booting him in the head and cracking them full blast
in the head with Bhutan's while they're unconscious.
They s this guy jumped on this woman.
One guy was dragging her and this guy jumped and stomped on her chest.
She was a woman.
She had a bra on.
It was like a blue bra.
She was skinny and he just jumped up and stomped down on our chest.
It is inhumane.
It's horrific to watch and you know,
that's,
that country right now is fucked.
There's,
you know,
it's,
it's the new boss.
Same as the old boss,
you know,
all the sudden this guy who had been running shit as a dictator for 20 plus
years has gone.
And who the fuck runs things?
No,
I do.
And then there's a jocking and there's just crazy lawlessness now.
It's horrific to watch,
man.
When you see that,
when you see these protesters getting beaten,
like that man that the savagery involved,
it's just like,
man,
you have no concern for their health or wellbeing.
It was like if people were running,
shooting,
just running and shooting guns,
running forward towards these people towards the protest to and just shooting
guns,
I'm in it.
They are not taking it.
Where do you see that video on Youtube?
Man,
it was on youtube because it's not graphic.
You can't see any blood or anything.
You know,
it's like kind of shitty quality.
What's up with shitty quality nowadays?
I mean come on.
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
She has some old ass fucking Motorola cell phone.
Yeah.
I mean that's what it was filmed on.
I don't know.
It was filmed on now you know where you dropped it as cell phones off in the
boxes.
Lance is like donate your cell phones.
I it goes to Egypt,
it goes to anywhere in the world is fucked up.
Yeah.
I think the,
the,
the economic pain that were kind of feeling,
it's bad.
I mean definitely a lot of people are hurting but it's not too great depression
levels right now.
You know,
it's not even to levels that we've already seen happen before here in America.
And I think everybody recognizes that we are right now in a very unshaking
exactly.
Foundation one.
And when it gets worse,
then the occupy movement,
I mean,
what's going to,
cause you know,
the people who are on the fringe to just come out in numbers.
I think there'll be a kind of a tipping point effect where people are going to
be like,
fuck this.
Fuck the corruption in the government.
We need a new system.
You know,
we need to stop spending money to bail out the banks.
We need what you less so ever
convinced the government to revamp the system and take away their power and how
they would ever do that.
It takes an uprising like that.
I mean it takes,
it takes the people to cause the movement and when has the government ever done
shit without the people moving first.
I mean women's suffrage for example of women weren't marching around doing that
thing.
They may still not be able to vote.
I mean it takes the people rising up in order to change the government's the
only fucking way because power is going to breed power.
They're going to just keep the snitch system status quo.
I mean maybe one or two examples where Lincoln abolish slavery,
you know,
on his own kind of,
before there was massive upscale,
but that was during a time of war.
It had certain advantages,
et cetera.
There is a variety of different things involved in that,
but it's always the people who demand something first that caused the government
to change.
And I think,
you know,
right now people are talking and they're talking voice.
I think pretty soon they're going to have to start yelling and I think that's
ultimately what's going to happen and change.
But before they start yelling,
unfortunately they'd asked to hurt worse.
And I think that's probably where we're heading,
you know,
as to is the more economical,
and I never thought this was going to be going down.
I remember when you were younger when Clinton was president and looked like the
world is just a rosy fucking beautiful place to be.
I miss that guy just he was just a comfortable guy.
What an amazing and a comfortable time.
20 years,
20 years a world has just changed beyond recognition almost.
But I think it's part of the natural cycle of things.
I mean,
things don't go in a steady curve.
They have to go in these cycles.
These,
you know,
gets way too far out of line.
Then it maybe goes back too far the other way.
I mean,
probably there'll be a point where,
you know,
the sentiments get too roused in the other direction.
You're like,
wait,
wait a minute.
You know,
we gotta have banks,
we've got to have this need to keep civilization together.
We need credit cards.
I don't want to be carrying gold bullion.
Let's pull the shit together.
God,
goddammit.
Yeah.
It's just,
you know,
we've got to get rid of,
you got to get rid of that stock market.
I watched that fucking thing on TV.
I sound like a grandpa.
I watched that stock market.
We've got to get rid of that.
But I watched it on TV.
I was watching some won some financial report and there's the ticker tape going
on because it,
cause it's like an alien program to me.
The ticker tapes going on beneath it.
And then,
you know,
this guy starts talking about,
uh,
you know,
a lack of confidence in this company and a confidence that there's a lot of
confidence behind this company and I'm watching these numbers spin.
I'm like,
this is insanity.
This is like,
these guys are like,
there's like a,
a virus,
a virus of numbers is horrible like hurricane,
like virus of numbers.
And then there's a few people in there that sort of know how to decipher it and
they're pulling numbers out and seeing which way the waves are blowing.
I'm like,
what a wacky fucking system based on confidence.
What?
Based on how people feel about companies and shit and whether or not a new
product just came out,
oh we're going to buy by apple by,
by,
and you can actually,
you know,
you can affect that somehow.
Like what,
what kind of,
what,
what are we basing on any of our time on this wonky shit for this is a
ridiculous set up.
The speculatory frenzy around stocks and these things is pretty outrageous and
it really,
it takes away from what originally the idea is,
which is to own a,
share an interest in a company that you thought was going to make money and do
things as a positive form of investment.
You know,
ultimately really wacky.
Was it the Reagan administration when,
when they,
when were they allowed to do,
like when did they allow women to let loud have like derivatives and stuff?
Probably in the 80s in the 80 [inaudible] got it.
Got The wackiest cause the markets were still pretty new in the 70s and things.
I mean,
but the stock market has had its nonsenses since the 1920s.
I mean you can read the big crash of the stock operator and there was some of
the same madness,
but there were safeguards who were put in place after the big crash of the
whatever it was,
the 20s into Great Depression.
Um,
there was,
there were safeguards that are put in place that were eventually dropped,
right?
Weren't there?
Yeah.
I mean,
depending on how much the market can drop in a certain day,
basically limits so it can go limit down.
There's,
there's a lot of those things in different,
in different commodities markets as well.
There'll be a limit to how far the price can move in one day.
But the thing is that's just per day.
They don't limit it permanently cause that would cause massive inefficiency.
So it just kinda curves that initial panic like holy fuck,
we got to sell everything,
sell,
and then lots of way below where it needs to and then the margin calls kick in
and then people,
you know,
lose all their money.
They're jumping out of buildings.
It's just a mess.
At that point.
They tried to curb that so ridiculous this buy,
buy,
sell,
sell.
It seems so ridiculous that accompany could actually,
like we'll go by that like that could have any sense whatsoever in the world of
business and still,
but looking at these equity markets,
they're way better off than the credit markets.
Then the debt markets,
that's where all of these problems are going.
People swap and debt and derivatives and all of these things.
I mean,
at least these are companies,
at least ultimately at the end of the day,
you can poke a CEO and the chest and hold something,
a service or a product that he created at the company,
created a,
you know,
all of these other pieces.
What are they?
There's these numbers that are circulated in a variety of ways where everybody
makes money and if you lose money,
guess what?
You don't lose money because the government will bail you out.
So how the fuck are they not going to do that?
A no risk.
It's a no risk situation.
You know?
Let's,
yeah,
let's be super aggressive.
Let's be super risky.
We'll make a bunch of money on the way up.
If we lose,
no big deal.
Uncle Sam will come in,
they'll pay it all.
I mean,
how are we not expected for them to have it?
That's why I think one of my biggest beefs with the occupy Wall Street movement
is,
you know,
really should be occupy Washington.
I mean,
you're telling these sharks that,
hey,
play this game.
You can make all the money you want and if you lose,
we're going to bail you out.
Well,
who's fault is that?
They're going to be sharks.
Sharks are going to be sharks.
These men are putting their positions for being greedy,
for being the most aggressive in their,
in their,
of their class.
And then we're expecting them to behave in these dramatically
moral ways and not do it.
No,
it's not going to happen if they have no,
you know,
no room for failure at the end of the day.
Why the fuck wouldn't they do that?
Has there ever been a stock market movie where they weren't really in it for the
money and they would just kind of really cool guys.
So a lot of principals stock market moving.
I saw a tower heist with the Eddie Murphy and um,
um,
uh,
who the fuck is it?
The other guy,
Ben Stiller.
Jesus Christ.
How can I blank on Ben Stiller?
Hilarious fucking movie.
Really.
But again,
evil banker,
you know,
evil stock market guy.
Is there ever a nice stock market guy?
Like,
you know,
think about like a boiler room.
Everyone's doing coke.
Everyone's fucking crazy.
They're all over the edge.
Is there a stock market movie where everybody's like really cool?
It's a breed of animal.
It's like I to go to work with pictures of their kids Bible passages.
It's like asking if there's a great white shark movie where the shark doesn't
eat the fuck out of people.
Go.
Yeah,
get the fuck out of people.
It's just the nature of the beast.
I mean there's some great stock guys,
I've known a lot of them,
some great hedge fund managers,
but you know,
ultimately they are super aggressive and they're going to take advantage of any
market that they see.
There's a dude I used to do taekwondo with who became a stock market guy and I
didn't see him for a couple of weeks and I saw him.
It was like he had a suit on and shit and I was like,
what are you doing man?
I'm like,
what's going on with you?
And he's like,
look dude,
I'm fucking selling stocks.
Fuck it.
He was like this really aggressive psycho dude.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden he was like really into this game of selling stocks,
but the way he was talking about was like it was going to financial war every
day.
He will fuck them bitches up,
bro.
We got,
we got the fucking best team.
They know.
Let me invest so many money.
Get the fuck Outta here.
What?
This crazy ass hole.
No,
I know.
It's a silly system.
Weird.
Show me your impersonation of a sad north Korean.
Oh,
oh.
Stepping down.
It's like the worst acting ever.
Every time a camera's on them.
Like you're sad,
you're sad.
Fallen down.
Oh
pressing,
no tears,
no tears.
Documentary the other day in that country,
and this was right before he died,
I was like,
I watched this and it was showing like how all the kids are like,
people are blind and North Korea,
they're going blind because their,
their diets are so bad that they're getting cataracts and there was kids,
just tons of kids with cataracts because there,
how poor their diet is.
I mean,
wow,
40%.
I think it was a 40 or 45% of the children in North Korea are starving like,
like,
like dying because of starvation.
If you're interested in any of this,
go to vice guide for North Korea.
Go to vice.com and check out the thing that they have up cause they have a,
uh,
a bunch of shit today,
including all this North Korean,
uh,
labor camp footage where they have all the little slaves slave footage.
That's crazy.
And that's,
that's what the whole country,
uh,
is around those slave.
That's what makes the
fear that makes all these people act this way is because of the slave camps.
Yeah.
The people have no power there.
I mean,
it's really amazing what,
and when you see a dictatorship,
like it's horrific.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's the worst way a human being can be treated,
but it's also quite impressive.
It's really amazing that some guy is just allowed to just straight run shit.
You know,
like in Thailand,
some American just got locked up in jail,
I think for a year for talking bad about the king.
The king,
the king actually doesn't even run.
Yeah.
In the country in Thailand as far as I remember from when I was like,
you can't talk shit about it.
But there is a special rule about,
about talking bad about the king.
You know,
it's a,
it's a weird situation where they have some kind of control on the verbiage
towards the king,
but he actually has not as much governmental power as,
um,
as the general other Thai leaders.
I don't know what they have as far as that's interesting person,
but yeah.
He apparently,
he's like legitimately beloved.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's not amazing.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a strange fucking place,
man,
is
do you think we're withdrawing our troops so we can send them into North Korea?
Dude,
we're not going on North Korea.
No minerals in North Korea.
There's no goal in North Korea is there's a whole country of people that are
kind of,
I don't know.
That's kind of Nazi shit,
in my opinion,
is,
well,
it's Communist.
Dictatorship is 100% like that.
I mean it's,
it's actually worse than Nazi,
right?
I mean,
I don't want to say worse,
but you don't think it's team America?
Same exact vein of it,
you know?
I mean,
they're not out there causing genocide and attacking other nations,
but I mean,
they're puking,
you know,
that's a terrible way to live.
You know what about it?
They said that Kim Jong was the number one buyer of Hennessy,
number one single person that buys the most of Hennessy.
Do you almost imagine kind of fucking rapper parties?
He must have had,
rappers are so mad about that right now,
that price they're going to,
they're going to change that.
Do you think,
do you think maybe that the,
that we have our planning set up by the way?
No,
it's 100% true.
I swear to fucking God,
look it up.
Leave you.
But do you think maybe that we a poisoned Kim Jong to give him a heart attack
and you think what were planning all this to go to North Korea?
No,
he's an old dude.
But it is kind of fun if you want to be a conspiracy theorist and really start
thinking about it and think about,
you know,
Gadhafi and Osama bin Ladin and Kim Jong Il and all Mubarak's gone.
Think about all these people who've been moved,
replace or died just really recently.
It's like,
have you ever seen a general Anthony?
What does is no,
Wesley Clark,
do you remember that guy that was running for president for awhile?
He's a,
I think he's a general,
some bad ass army guy.
And uh,
let me,
let me look it up so I can give him
the right.
May just be part of this sign of the times have changed that it's kind of
sweeping over everybody.
It seems like there's this tumultuous period,
you know,
as we're coming into this this age,
it's causing change
to happen at a more rapid rate.
You,
Brian,
pull up the plan.
I want you to pull up the plan according to General Wesley Clark.
You can just Google Wesley Clark General Wesley Clark and this'll come up in
youtube.
Um,
but my point was this general Wesley Clark actually in I believe it was 2007 he
predicted all of this and he said,
this is the plan.
This is what they want to do.
They're going to get rid of Gaddafi.
They're going to go into this country.
They're going to take over an Iraq who are going to kill Saddam Hussein.
I mean,
he like literally spells it out.
Everything that we did,
right?
10 days after nine 11,
I went to the Pentagon and I shot Secretary Rumsfeld and and deputy searcher
woeful,
which I went downstairs just shale over some of the people on the joint staff
who would use general western crying.
One of the generals call me and he said,
sir,
you got to come in and you got to come in and talk to me a second.
I said,
well,
you're too busy.
He said,
no,
no.
He says,
we've made the decision.
We're going to war with Iraq.
This was on or about the 20th of September.
I said,
we're going to war with Iraq.
Why?
He said,
I don't know.
I guess they don't know what else to do.
So,
uh,
I said,
well,
did they find some information,
collect connecting,
sit to al Qaeda?
He said,
no,
no.
It was just,
there's nothing new that way.
They've just made the decision to go to war with Iraq.
He said,
I guess it's like we don't know what to do about terrorists,
but we've got a good military and we can take down governments.
So I came back to see him a few weeks later and by that time we were bombing in
Afghanistan.
I said,
are we still going to war with Iraq?
And he said,
oh,
it's worse than that.
You said he reached over on his desk.
He picked up a piece of paper and he said,
I just,
he said,
I just got this down from upstairs,
mean saturated benched office today.
And he said,
this is a memo that describes how we're going to take out seven countries in
five years starting with Iraq and in Syria,
11 on Libya,
Somalia,
Sudan,
and finishing off Iran
to go through the countries again.
We're all starting with Iraq and Syria and Lebanon.
Then Libya than Somalia and Sudan and then back to her ran.
Okay.
Ask her what 2007 wow.
This is the General Wesley Clark.
I mean,
this is,
you know,
he's not a Kook,
Jesus Christ and Nutty,
but it's weird that he would,
uh,
I mean,
is he still alive if you know that?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
he's,
he's alive man.
But I mean,
if you,
if you know that and you don't tell,
you're probably much more likely to get killed.
You know what I'm saying?
It's true.
Like you,
you might be thinking about telling somebody that once it's out.
Yeah.
Once it's out,
it's out.
And if they get you,
it's almost obvious.
But if,
you know,
if you've worked one of these dudes and you know some shit like that,
she better get on a talk show son.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know what I like,
if someone knows that,
you know that,
I mean,
I'm sure they wouldn't tell Wesley Clark because he's a fucking general.
And on top of that,
he's probably been a part of a bunch of shit in his past,
but maybe he did may agree combination to a lock box with a lot worse.
Sure.
It shows up unexplainably dead.
Yeah.
And look,
nobody knows more about how the world really runs in high ranking generals
period.
You know,
they get pushed into situations where they absolutely know that they're doing it
for a very specific reason.
That uh,
Smedley Butler,
a article that was written in the 1930s war is a racket,
you know,
amazing,
amazing article.
When you think about the fact that this guy wrote this in like,
I think it was like 19 something,
1930 something and you would say,
you know,
back then,
man,
there's no way people had figured it out back then.
You know,
people were wearing,
uh,
a corrupt country back then.
Back then all the wars were just,
it was real bad people over there.
Not according to this dude,
man,
this is a major u s marine,
Major General Smedley Butler,
and it's a really brilliant,
is 19.
Actually in 1930 he wrote,
yeah,
it was published in 1935 but he wrote it in 1930 it's called war is a racket and
this guy,
uh,
had a career in the military and got out and just said,
listen,
this is how it goes.
Wars are racking.
It always has been.
It's possibly the oldest,
easily the most profitable.
Surely the most vicious.
It is the only one international in scope.
It is the only one which the profits are reckoned in dollars in the losses in
lives.
Arachat is best described,
I believe,
as something that is not what it seems to be to the majority of the people.
Only a small inside group knows what it's about.
It's conducted for the benefit of the very few,
at the expense of the very many out of war.
Few people can make huge fortunes and this is a 19 motherfucking 30.
This guy wrote that because that incredible.
It's like
he sucked,
really sucked.
We just been better recovering it up.
If we had the internet in 1930,
you know,
people would be like,
what the fuck are we?
Why are we in Mexico?
You know,
what's going on in Haiti?
What are we doing in Cuba?
There's probably some truth to that.
I think the,
so if we had to do it that we've,
we've talked about this Joe,
so if we had to,
uh,
if we had to start it all over,
let's say some cataclysm happens,
economic collapse happens,
a situation where like minded people who were able to before it happens.
Say,
all right,
listen,
we got to scope out in North Dakota.
This is going to be our spot.
Let's go there.
Is that the only way to do it or is it possible that the way to do it is to not
have everything completely fall apart,
but everybody's sort of come to some sort of an understanding?
I would much rather have that absolutely.
Maybe we can ease into a second economy by starting off slowly.
Like you don't have to use the entire un,
you know,
don't,
you don't have to use US currency.
Maybe we can have an alternative currency that we all agreed to.
They tried that in the US,
the Austrian town of [inaudible] during the Great Depression,
I think 1932.
And it's a pretty interesting story.
The,
the currency had had two features,
one that it was commodities backed,
so it wasn't just backed by gold,
which is one way to do it.
But the problem with just the gold back is your,
that's contingent on people actually Viking Goldstone then one and goal that if
someone's going to wake up eventually the fuck is this gold.
You can't eat it.
You can't,
you can't kill anybody with it.
Make Hammers.
Yeah.
So you make a catapult,
right.
So you gotta I mean,
obviously go,
it'd be,
yeah,
it'd be a heavy something,
but a no good weapon.
If you could catapult a bowl of giant gold ball,
fuck you up,
man.
It was what it cost.
Ironic.
Way To die.
Well,
you know the whole story about the Zechariah stitching story about why gold was
valuable to ancient humans.
Yeah.
He believes that the Ammo knocky who created the human out of,
uh,
the,
the lower hominid and the alien genetics would,
they needed us to mine for gold because they needed gold and massive amounts to
suspend in their atmosphere to protect their atmosphere.
It sounds completely ridiculous,
but when you really go back to like how long people have been using gold and
they were like nomads man.
Like why,
what did you give a fuck about this little shiny,
weird,
soft metal that you can't even make a tool out of owl?
This Huxley has a different theory that I think is actually pretty interesting
as well.
He says that the reason people like gold is cause it approximates some of the
shiny visions that you see under the psychedelic or mystic experience.
So that's the reason why we like gems.
That's the reasons why we like gold.
I mean now metal is everywhere.
It's ubiquitous.
But back then that was the only shiny shit that you found in the earth was metal
that you mind right now.
We mass produce it.
So it's not that you know,
mystical are beholding anymore,
but he says,
you know,
he's like,
why are we digging in the dirt to find these shiny pebbles still?
And he says it's because when you're on these kinds of mescaline or DMT or are
these other experiences,
you see these multifaceted,
you know,
colors and lights and shine.
You know,
different kind of makes sense to me.
But many more people have gotten into diamonds and rubies then have had
psychedelic experiences.
Right?
But we're all,
but we all know some knowledge of that realm,
you know,
and that's his,
that's his idea.
His concept is that your mind is just a filter and it symbolizes this,
the things that you see so that you can walk around and you do the normal daily
stuff.
But when you remove that filter,
like through psychedelics or through other different methods,
some of that starts to peer through and you see the colors in the way that they
are in the void and the different aspects outside of our physical confines.
And that's what's so mystical about them.
And that's why we seek that.
Even if we haven't seen it in psychedelics,
we know it.
And that's part of like,
you know,
part of our soul and knowledge or at least part of the collective mind at large.
Well,
everyone's had a dream.
Any dream state is just,
might as well be a psychedelic experience.
I mean,
how many times have dream states just been like,
you know,
you're involved in something that is just completely ridiculous.
It makes no sense and you're just kinda going with it,
you know?
I mean,
that's all.
I got a lot of like really nutty,
crazy dreams,
right?
Well,
that is a,
like a second dog experience and most likely even caused by psychedelic
compounds in the brain.
This,
they've don't totally understand how that works,
man.
They don't totally understand like why dimethyltryptamine is in your brain and
five methoxy dimethyltryptamine and when is it actually released?
The,
there's like theories that it's released in periods of high stress and there's
something like the anecdotal evidence,
but they really have to develop these,
uh,
much more,
sensitive ways of determining like when the actual DMT is released during
various stages of human activity.
Because right now,
from what I understand,
one of the only ways to find out is when someone dies,
like does DMT flood the brain when they die?
Well you have to like get in there like within seconds after they're dead and
measure that shit.
You know,
within,
you know,
I mean when you,
your body processes,
it's 10 15 minutes and you're back to baseline.
I mean it's,
so,
it's a really quick experience.
So like when someone dies,
if they get that blast,
if that's what happens and you know,
you have a psychedelic trip that like whether it eases your,
you know,
your departure from the earth or whether it opens up some fucking gateway to
something in nature that's next,
whatever the hell it is,
it's gone pretty good damn quickly.
It's Poof,
you know,
it's there and it's not,
so they would have to like open your fucking head up real quick and get to that
gland and then start testing.
Right.
I think maybe there's,
there's something to it obviously,
but what is it?
I mean,
yeah,
I spent a long time telling that story about the,
you know,
the,
the jungle when I was down there and taking Iowasca.
And since then I had a very deep,
um,
you know,
silicide been experience and in contrast and,
uh,
there's something particular about the DMT molecule that I'm convinced that's
transcend area to what,
you know,
in the framework of the jungle where I was when I was there,
that's,
you know,
causes you to go to different dimensions than even a suicide and trip.
I felt,
I felt like there was the DMT molecule is some form of gateway that opens doors
that you can't even get,
you know,
with other energy medicine,
psychoactive compounds.
There's something particularly special about that.
And uh,
I couldn't,
couldn't help but feel that overwhelming feeling.
I actually was able to,
I saw a lot of the same kind of figures and a lot of things like trying to pull
me up and like,
that was the large part of my vision was these reaching down in and trying to
pull me up into these higher levels.
But there's,
the fuel wasn't there.
Like I couldn't,
I couldn't open that door,
the same door that I went through back in the jungle.
And maybe that has something to do with the sham and maybe it has to do with the
other things,
but I think it has to do with totally different compound,
totally different compounds.
So each one has their own specialist.
I think that is a part of the compound of psilocybin.
I think nn dimethyltryptamine is actually like a part of it.
I think it's something like for Fox four [inaudible] and end dimethyltryptamine
it's so,
it's very closely related it and it certainly is,
but there was,
I don't know for whatever reason there was some,
some others,
maybe not.
How much did you have?
It was probably two and a half grams maybe since he left side.
But it was really,
yeah,
you got silly.
That's not enough.
You need five.
Five is the magic number.
Yeah.
But if I've taken,
I've taken a good amount of,
Brian did like seven recently and by mistake the world disappeared on him for a
little while.
Yeah.
There's different situations cause different,
different,
uh,
different results.
But it's a pretty remarkable,
I haven't done DMT in several years and uh,
it's been a couple because the last time I did it was the only time ever,
ever,
I mean,
I've had a lot of bunch of psychedelic experiences,
but the last time I did DMT was the only time where I ever was not sure what was
real and what was,
what was imagination and fantasy for about two weeks.
For about two weeks.
The world itself,
like as I was driving seemed malleable and like,
it seemed like if I concentrated on car accidents,
you know,
I might wind up in a fucking car accident,
if I concentrate on it raining out,
it might rain out.
I mean,
it sounded completely ridiculous and I didn't believe that I could make anything
happen with my mind at a,
by any stretch of the imagination.
But what I also didn't believe was that reality was 100% real.
Because what happens when you have a real mind blowing fucking trip is first of
all,
you get terrified that it's that close that Oh,
you have to do is smoke that stuff.
And it's right there.
I can get there in 30 seconds,
a minute and I get to some impossible place.
Like if you could,
if you had the journey across the earth to get to some spot in Tibet where you,
you know,
you look into the DMT realm,
you know you have to climb through a fucking cave and repel and you camp out
there and it takes days and some people die like climbing Mt.
Everest.
But if you get there,
if you get to that spot,
you look out and you see God,
you look out and you see the most purest wisdom,
the,
the most knowledgeable love,
the most sympathetic voice,
the most knowledge that you could ever possibly imagine coming from something in
a way that's not even language,
like very difficult to describe,
but so intense and humbling man.
People would,
they would take trips to go to that.
They would,
it would be,
you know what I'm saying?
Like if there was like a guy that you could go to,
they would give you this feeling.
But essentially there is,
and it's,
it's if,
if everyone knew,
if it was legal and you could go to places where they could prescribe it,
boy,
would that change the world?
I mean,
That changed the fucking,
if you seen,
if people have seen what you've seen,
could you imagine there are totally different,
but if you brought that up,
people say like,
you're a fucking crazy person.
Like what are you doing?
You got to give people drugs,
the hallucinations and they're going to,
oh,
that's gonna make them a better person while the driving another,
you know,
theory from Huxley is that the driving force behind all religion was seeking
that,
that kind of transcendental place.
And people got to it through a variety of different means.
He said,
you know,
all the chanting that you find in these mystical traditions
that raises the CO2 level because you end up breathing out more than you breathe
in when you're doing it.
Unless you're a highly trained singer,
you know,
and your expert.
But most of these ecstatic chanting and yelling and all that is designed to
raise that co two level breathe out more than you breathe in.
How's that even possible?
Just,
well,
just in a normal bread.
All sides as well.
Just cause no more [inaudible] it's like a rapper made that one of the
[inaudible] dick hole fills up my lungs from the bottom.
Yo.
Well anyway,
that's how he put it.
I there's some,
there's some ways really shit like that man.
It drives me nuts,
you know,
and then you repeated accidentally not,
not thinking about it and then you know someone else has to come along.
Go wait a minute man,
what the fuck did you just say?
And then he'd go,
yeah,
what the fuck did I just say?
God Damn,
I'm just repeating some stupid shit.
Somebody told me in martial arts I was always a problem.
There's always going,
could be the wrong way to go about it.
But either either case he's saying that was one mile example of raising the co
two levels.
There are certain breathing exercises.
It's certainly do that.
So that does something to the air.
It's more carbon dioxide that ends up reducing that what he calls the cerebral
reducing valve.
That is what keeps everything symbolized because that vision,
what you're talking about,
you're saying it's right there.
It's right there because it's around us all the time.
And that's why when you take something or smoked Dmt,
you get to it instantly.
You don't have to travel to it cause it's there all the time.
The only thing.
But isn't it possible that it's also perturbing your mind and giving your mind
a,
an excess of chemicals to deal with.
So it distorts your visual perception of the world.
I mean it seems to me that there you have to look at every single possibility
and you have to look at the possibility that if the brain produces all these
different chemicals at varying doses and we believe that it varies the doses
based on stress levels.
Wow.
There might be something to that.
There might be something to this possibility that there is a gateway,
but there's also a possibility that you just getting fucked up on some wacky
drug and seeing some nutty shit.
And it's so humbling because you don't expect it,
that when you come back,
you have like all these rationalizations and all this,
you know,
this either way,
if you believe that it can make you a great person,
it's like,
you know,
like a lot of religions,
man.
I don't think there's anything wrong Christianity.
I mean,
if it works for you,
it works for you.
I know people that it works for them and it actually does make them a better
person,
you know?
Um,
and if you believe in it,
it can work.
It can make you a better person,
you know?
And if you believe that your psychedelic experience was truly connecting with
the divine well,
that can make you a better person.
But it could also be your system is just over flooded by some shit that's not
supposed to be there and rocket fuel doses.
And it was just a wash.
And like usually when it gets a sip of,
it's at the bottom of a river of,
of,
you know,
this crazy fucking fluid.
That's,
I think that's us actually,
I think a more accepted theory than houses,
which is that you're actually taking away your filter instead of adding
something else.
And he on to talk about,
you know,
probably more convincing arguments than the chanting argument basically that um,
there was a famous st that the curate to ours,
uh,
this,
this French saint and he used to say that when he would flagellate himself,
God could deny him nothing and he would have access to that Ms. Dot.
Was about popular thing.
Right?
Yeah.
People don't know that means you're beat the fuck out of yourself.
So you would do it,
you know,
so these long periods and pull a fart out or something.
Oh,
flatulence.
You know flagellate it's like they use like a little whip did either nodded
leather or actual barbs on it and it would cause they're back to bleed when he
was tearing themselves apart and the era before soap that would cause,
you know,
first of all the actual beating would cause a lot of adrenaline to rush through
your body and Histamines to rush through your body as,
as this was going on,
that in combination with the fasting that was very popular,
obviously lent winter was kind of a forced fast.
And with the flagellation that caused,
you know,
an error before soap,
there's would almost always fester.
So there would be all these decomposing protein in your system.
It would basically reduce your,
you know,
your cerebral capacity to the point where you could enter psychedelic trance
states and actually commune,
you know,
with God underneath your,
oh Whoa,
whoa,
break that shit down again.
So you're saying because they were dirty,
stinky people that didn't wash that good so they didn't like scrub off the
outside layer of skin that somehow the penetrating that would change their
state.
Well,
this is in combination with a variety of things.
So basically at the brain needs vitamins and nutrients to function.
Normally,
you know,
you go through these long periods of fasting.
That was one way to reach the mystical experience.
40 days of fasting,
you're basically denying your brain of all the glucose,
all the vitamins necessary to function optimally.
And that's when a lot of these people had visions.
While the reason they had visions according to Huxley was because the brain was
just not funk,
be able to function as its normal symbolizing cerebral nature that it does to
make us all survive.
So you were able to take in more of the capital m mind at large,
which we call the collective now because of the lack of vitamins.
And he was saying also the flagellation usually used in conjunction with that,
you know,
so you got your brain basically running on very little little,
just trying to hang in there and then you beat yourself.
And then at that point,
you know,
you got,
you got adrenaline,
you got histamines,
and then you got festering wounds on your back that are causing more,
you know,
more kind of toxins to your brain.
So at that point your brain just kind of shuts off and it allows more of that
mystical experience to come through.
Wow.
So you beat the fuck out of yourself to achieve enlightenment after you starve
yourself for a month or so.
Can you mention farts before?
So,
and that's,
but that's how,
that's how important seeking that mystical experience was.
These people,
they were willing to do that.
And how would they find out about it though?
Unless someone wants to meet someone and then there's someone said,
thank you for starving,
maybe beat the fuck out of me because I learned a lot about myself maybe,
maybe,
well the winter was basically a forced fast.
They had hardly any vitamin or in the winter that they were able to be able to
store a certain amount of things.
And then coming off winter was also a time that that caused a lot of these
visions to come.
And at that point,
yeah,
somebody may be got taken to the whip.
Whipping was a common,
was a common way to treat any kind of petty offense.
Someone gets whipped after 40 after three months of fasting for winter,
40 days of lent,
and they get whipped.
They very well may see God and that was his idea.
But he said now at the state that we know about psychedelics,
trying to get to the mystical state through that reason is like,
you know,
burning the house down to cook a pig.
You know,
it's like you don't need to do that anymore.
You can go out and you can find these tools that were placed here on
the earth that's get you that experience really amazing.
And I never heard that before.
I'd never heard that before about the flagellation and starving.
It totally makes sense.
Yeah,
it's a crazy a possibility.
I've always wondered why the fuck they beat the shit on themselves.
I just figured it's like Jerry Sandusky,
like they hate themselves.
You know,
to hear.
One of the things that Jason Dusky said,
and one of the interviews he said he wished he was dead.
You know,
he's talking to this woman.
The woman was asking him like,
why he touched her son or any sign.
I didn't mean it to be that way.
I wish I was dead.
Wow.
You know,
like that's like these big horn cells,
whips with fucking Barb's.
That's a person that hates himself,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
the guilt,
the guilt that was fostered by the beliefs and the time,
I mean would cause people to hate themselves.
They'd have this constant sense of nine guilt that they couldn't get rid of.
So how do you get rid of guilt?
Well,
somebody has to punish you if nobody else is going to do it.
Punish yourself.
Isn't it amazing how the human mind can be programmed like that with religion or
with nationalism,
you know,
with North Korea or whether it's to fucking inquisition.
It's amazing,
really.
It's amazing the human beings can all fall into a pattern.
The pattern just has to be really clear and enforced and scare the fuck out of a
few people.
While it's being enforced and then boom,
it's a,
it spreads,
you know,
it's really amazing.
It's just,
we're so weird,
you know,
we're capable of such brilliance and such beauty,
but we're also so fucking dumb.
We're so easy to trick.
Or some of them were so easy to program and,
and,
and make act completely ridiculous and absurd.
What's so easy?
Well I think there's,
there's a couple of things that are going on there.
I think there's a certain amount of people who are very easily programmable and
I've,
I've read some figures,
some estimations that there's 20% of the population,
uh,
like,
like a hypnotist who brings a bunch of people up on stage.
Those certain people are very,
you know,
very susceptible to suggestion was to bring this up because people think I'm a
dummy.
I've got a bunch of tweets from people,
the real leg,
fuck you.
Stupid comedy hypnotist aren't real.
I know you don't think they're real.
Cause guess what?
I didn't think they're real either.
When I first saw a comedy show,
it's stitches comedy Club in Boston.
I saw Frank Santos to are rated hypnotist.
And I said,
this is bullshit.
This is so fucking stupid.
This is bullshit.
But it's not bullshit.
It just wouldn't work on you.
Yu,
the skeptical person
that's like,
this is bullshit.
Generally you probably fairly intelligent and it's not going to work on you.
Right?
But if you're one of those dudes with a nine volt brain,
there's a lot of people out there like that.
You can hypnotize them.
It doesn't seem like it should work.
It seems completely preposterous to you or to me or to you because you,
we couldn't be hypnotized like that.
Right.
But to that dude,
it's absolutely possible and that's amazing.
It's like,
it's almost like there's people set up around us and we have the cheat codes for
them,
you know,
and you throw it,
throw it,
throw them into God mode,
you know,
like literally,
literally like people can be hacked.
That's amazing.
And people and people know that had been taking advantage of that.
So there's that factor.
There's this 20% let's say people that can be basically hypnotizer basically
walking somnambulists,
you know,
like able to be hypnotized easily.
Is that a biological thing?
I think so.
I think it's just the way that their mind works in a certain way.
And I don't think it's necessarily a lack of intelligence.
It's just a certain circuitry that their mind works on where they're at,
that it goes,
I don't know.
Definitely the lack of objective reasoning.
Sure,
sure.
Part of the mind is probably getting steered around for a certain cause that
hardly rational individual,
but they're,
you know,
their emotional intelligence might be off the charts,
like they might be able to be very insightful as far as their intuition and what
they're able to see.
But,
but certainly there's some critical aspect that they're able to just circumvent
and shut off completely.
And,
and that's,
that's I think obvious.
But once you get that majority,
let's say that 20% human beings are naturally creatures,
social creatures.
So if you start to see a majority,
like it's,
if you start to see a bunch of people running,
you know,
you're going to start jogging the same direction and be like,
Oh shit,
I don't know what I'm jogging,
but these people are fucking going and I'm outta here.
So I think that's part of what happens.
They get a certain minority,
you know,
convinced,
hypnotize,
basically just some nonsense and then everybody else is like,
Oh shit,
look at all these people.
They can't all be wrong.
And then they hop on board as well.
It's amazing.
We have to fix the design of the human body.
You know,
I was just saying this on stage for years that we've got to stop making,
having sex have to do with making babies.
That's ridiculous.
It should be way harder to make babies and it should be based,
you know,
on you,
you should have to like do something,
you know,
together.
Maybe go do something,
go somewhere to get to go through a ceremony together and then you make a baby.
Horse shoes have to be easier.
Like it has to be an APP on your phone.
That problem.
The problem with abortion is the abortion idea.
It's like got to catch it quick,
he catch it quick and it doesn't count.
It's like well are you sure?
Cause it is.
It is it,
it doesn't count or is it like stepping on an ant?
Like,
if I step on an ant in my house,
nine times out of 10 I don't even clean it up.
If I step on a mouse,
I got to clean it up,
you know?
And basically if a mouse is a size of an ant,
I wouldn't give a fuck.
All right.
There's,
there's something about when things get bigger that they start becoming real.
That's crazy.
You know?
I mean there's a,
there's a lot of holes in that argument.
There's a lot of,
it's a weird sort of an acceptance of what's essentially killing a life.
You know,
if you let it go,
it is going to be another person.
So what,
what you decide,
and I'm not saying you shouldn't have the right to choose because you absolutely
shouldn't.
And I don't want to be the one that tells you what to do with your body.
Don't get me wrong,
but as a philosophical argument of,
of what it is and when,
when does it start and when,
when is it life,
you know,
it's like,
how about we just figured out a way to completely prevent it unless you want it.
That seems like much smarter.
Like we should be doing that to kids at a like a really early age.
I'm not saying we should neuter him,
but we should fucking get them on birth control.
Lickety split,
you know gummy bear.
Well Jesus.
Yeah,
like give them a chance to get out of high school and keep them,
you know,
when you're in high school and your bone and your raw dogging it and you're
barely pulling out on time,
then it's like the best time to make a person.
Like your body's ready to go.
Your buddies young and fresh and you'd got bitches there.
Eggs are fallen into their socks.
You know,
there's so many eggs,
man,
they're ready to drop.
It's so easy to have a baby then and that's just the most ridiculous thing ever.
You know,
the worst set up,
the same way that we were set up back when it was really hard to stay alive.
We know are our biological setup is set up for back when we didn't have houses,
you know,
we were out there with sleeping under the stars.
One guy had to stay awake with a stick.
You know,
and then we're wondering around chasing after these animals cause we have to
follow the herd.
Otherwise we'll starve to death.
You know,
God damn man.
What a shit design.
Yeah,
the whole world is changed and we're the same.
That's what's really fucked up.
We in our little fucking interesting minds have figured out a way to manipulate
the earth so radically that we've polluted the ocean and fucked up the,
the air and left big fucking giant spots where no one can go for a hundred
thousand years.
There's a gang of them.
Well we drop nuclear bombs just to fucking see what would happen.
We had to get rid of nuclear waste.
We've done this like we've done it so quickly.
It's really amazing.
And,
but we're the same animal that we were 50,000 years ago.
Not that I was creating so many of the problems.
I mean,
I think the,
uh,
the Guy Maltus he's a politician and you know,
economist and he basically said food production increases arithmetically and you
know,
population increases geometrically so that ultimately,
you know,
the way things are going and we see this and all of these third world countries,
reproduction has far outpaced,
you know,
the amount of food supply and the things,
and this happens at various periods in history.
And so either nature is going to take care of it either in one fell swoop
through a giant famine or through disease or through other kind of
overpopulation of facts.
Then nature will kind of auto correct these mistakes.
Or you have to take different methods of contraception very seriously and start
teaching that,
you know,
at an early age.
And you know,
putting that in people's minds from the start.
And I think that's one area where we're terrible at.
I mean,
we don't want to talk about fucking still preaching abstinence,
which is nonsense.
Just that Michele Bachmann is hilarious.
It is amazing that broad is still running for president.
It is amazing with her big gay husband when they run around and tell everybody
not to have sex.
I mean,
it is really fucking funny,
man.
Somebody got a fall.
That dude around.
I mean,
I can't,
I,
you know,
I started paying attention to the polls and you know when Ron Paul,
especially when Ron Paul's ahead in Iowa right now,
he's got the lead.
He's number one in Iowa and everybody shit in their pants.
But that Michele Bachmann broad,
she's still in it,
man.
She's still in it.
She's in it to win it.
She's,
I can't believe it.
I would've thought,
doesn't everybody know she's off fucking loon?
Like have it,
hasn't that been figured out yet?
Have you seen her husband?
Have you seen him talk like that guy can't hold it in?
Flowers come out of his asshole.
What he farts,
I mean,
he's a guy.
If he threw his hands up randomly in the air,
glitter would just magically come out of the air.
It wouldn't matter whether it was,
you know,
whether it came from his skin or came from the universe recognizing that gayness
that he exudes,
it needs to be a glorified glitter.
He could create glitter,
he can create.
He,
he's a fucking peacock man.
He's hilarious.
He's one of the gayest people to ever walk the face of the planet.
At least he looks like he,
yeah.
Yeah.
And she's running around talking about about gay marriage and you know,
and they have a pray the gay away sort of a clinic for the one guy did an expo
say on there,
pray the gay away clinic and there was a guy behind him.
Somehow or another,
they do this thing where they all get together and they hold onto each other and
he says,
the guy behind him clearly has a hard on
the fuck you doing,
man.
And these people are running for president,
It's amazing.
But she's got a lot of people that think that she can win.
I mean,
not enough to actually win,
I don't think,
unless everybody else fucks up bat.
But the problem is they keep fucking up.
Everybody keeps talking about.
It's like there's no,
Rick Perry is still in it,
but it's just cursory at this point.
It's like,
what is he doing?
Come on dude.
Everybody knows you're an idiot.
You know,
like you're done,
man.
You fucking can't talk.
All right.
You forget shit.
And you know,
you're like,
George Bush was way better and people were offended by how dumb he was.
You know,
Rick Perry's like really fucking stupid.
George Bush was better than this guy,
like way better at talking,
you know?
I mean,
he seemed like,
you know,
he wasn't an intellectual,
but he seemed like,
especially back when he was running for governor,
if it seems like you put some fucking words together,
this guy's an embarrassment.
So it was like,
who else does,
no one laughed.
I mean,
what Mitt Romney and fucking,
um,
the other guy with a big head,
it's gotta be around Paul.
Yeah.
But yeah,
but really that seemed,
I mean,
they got to let that happen.
I doubt it.
But Mitt Newt Gingrich,
how hilarious is that?
That's like somebody that,
you know what that would be like if new king,
which should be president.
It'd be like if you dated this girl and she was a cunt and her dad was a country
or cunt,
that's Newt Gingrich.
You know,
like if you dated a girl and she was just a fucking choose nagging pain in the
ass
and then you had to go over and meet her parents and her dad is like,
you better be nice to my daughter.
I'll tell you that right now.
I don't take any bullshit from kids,
you know?
Oh,
can I deal with your dad?
He's like,
someone's dad,
he's a monster.
Where does glitter go?
You never throw glitter away.
Is it like,
are we breathing in glitter or are we starting with complex on where you live
because you have glitter on your right now you don't even know it.
And it's like,
where does that go though?
Yeah,
it does.
It just fall on the ground and it's the strip clubs now it's on your,
on your face right below your elbow from my little ones.
They have when you have little ones and they have glitter.
We always playing with glitter is always like glue and glitter.
There was making things.
Where does it go?
It gets thrown away.
I guess we're probably breeding glitter and you might go and die from good or
Brian,
don't worry about that shirt.
To go back to this,
the point that you had a,
you were talking about sex earlier,
cause I thought about this a lot for uh,
you know,
in building a society and some of the solutions that people had to,
to,
uh,
to the,
the population growth problem was actually teaching a form of Tantra,
which is where you withhold your seed when you're having sex.
So
in all fairness,
all fairness,
I gave it a go.
Right,
right.
And it's pretty,
it's pretty interesting,
the dynamics.
Now,
I don't think I would try this,
you know,
personally very often,
but if you created a system where you actually taught sex and this was one of
the ways that you could do it and not how was tantra any better than the pullout
method?
You know,
I don't,
I barely trust people to drive cars pull out all the time.
You know,
that feeling that you get,
it doesn't matter if you're having sex or if you're,
if you're masturbating,
whatever,
you get that feeling after you're done.
That's just kind of a bummer.
Anyway.
You look at it really,
it's kind of like,
ah yeah,
a little bit.
It's been way better with sex and masturbating.
Like if you're using a flashlight,
the feeling is like it's like 10 times,
but even when you're having sex it's like,
eh,
sometimes there's that that kind of really cool like glowy feeling afterward.
I guess.
I understand that,
but it kind of,
it kind of allows you to keep,
first of all,
it allows you to keep doing it like indefinitely for like a long period of time.
So you can just go to the point of climax and then you cool off,
you chill out,
you're hanging out and after,
you know,
after you do that with a person,
it's not like,
hey,
go get cleaned up.
We're going to,
you know,
sort something else out.
You're like still in the mindset.
So you can stretch it out for these long periods of time.
You're blue ball and yourself to death.
So you could basically occupy a massive amount of time having sex and it's
pretty,
it's pretty fun.
The chicken all drives like motherfucker lose just come
piece up for a little while.
But I mean that was one of the ideas that they,
that they taught.
I mean obviously contraception is super important but you know,
just teaching different methods is going to be vitally.
I don't think we should teach them Tantra fuck all day.
This is what I want you to do,
but hold onto your lows and fuck all day.
But imagine how much more entertaining that is.
Then just fucking for five minutes and then that's it.
That's all you're done.
You got to stretch out something that's constantly medium.
Yeah,
maybe.
a fucker.
And then take her out to dinner
and always do it in that order.
You know,
the worst is when you see a guy who takes a girl to a comedy club and he know he
hasn't fucked her yet and she's all mouthy and shit and yell and shit out,
and you're like,
why is this?
I'll tell you why.
Because you didn't fuck her.
You didn't fuck her before you leave.
And that's true shit.
If you gorilla fuck a girl before you leave the house,
she first of all,
she's not.
She's not trying to draw an extra tension.
Her genetics tell her she's already gotten fucked today.
Chill out.
You don't need any,
any extraordinary amount of attention.
Don't need me.
Extraordinary love.
Just settle the fuck down.
But if you don't fuck them,
and then you take them out into the wild and they're pumping out all those,
someone's going to fuck me tonight.
Hormones and it might be you.
Hopefully it's you,
but if she's a crazy bitch,
she's trying to like see if there's another offer out there.
She's like,
maybe,
maybe I'm not even to stay with him.
Who knows?
Whoa,
where it's fucking,
I'm funny.
A lot of those effects and not only evening dependent but whole relationship
depending on the shoe ever properly.
Never probably get by a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Or never been with a man.
I mean,
how many girls have you ever met that like date?
Like really weak do is because they're terrified of being in a situation where a
man controls them because either someone was a man was abusive earlier in their
life or they had a bad father relationship or stepfather relationship.
There's something where they shy away from any strong man,
you know,
where they were literally forced to be the man and the relationship and they
have,
I mean I know girls that are constantly involved in like Beta men,
like guys were like real issues that can never get it together.
They're always fucking falling behind on their bills.
They're always,
you know,
and these girls are always like nagging at them to get their shit together.
And it's this weird relationship man with a woman makes more of the money and
the woman pot pays for the car and he asked to borrow it from her when he wants
to go out.
And it's like,
wow.
You know,
it's,
it's such a clear situation to everybody else.
Like you'd see on the outside,
you're like,
look,
this is not good.
This is fucking completely unnatural dude.
There's a reason why she's yelling at you.
You know,
hey man,
we're all equal.
We're all even,
it's all the same.
Who cares man,
she makes the money.
You know,
I help out around the house,
the fuck Outta here.
You know,
there's no way you're fucking her correctly.
You've got to fuck her.
Like you have all the money.
That's the only way you're supposed to fuck them.
You're supposed to fuck them.
Like you have all the money,
dad,
he's going to take care of everything and he can't say that.
I just like,
daddy can't even take care of its own fucking car bill.
Oh bench make my dick go live and chickens ugly.
There's some definite masculinizing movement that has caused a whole crop of
males to be,
you know,
pretty ineffectual.
I think when it,
I think a lot of it is because women have to take care of themselves and they
don't want to hear bullshit.
And then men want those women to like them so they become emasculated,
emasculated,
divorce is brutal.
That chops away.
A guy living with your mom at a small age,
you know.
Awesome.
Oh,
just with your mom.
I lived with my mom and my sister.
It turned,
you know,
your boy,
I got to fuck with a real dog.
Well it's not a real,
but it's better
than a real doll.
Last they uh,
we had this Santa Roast at desk squad where we just roasted Sam AAA dress up as
Santa Claus and everyone and uh,
this company from called synthetics.com whoa.
I more than that picture.
And He,
he's this guy and his girlfriend.
Spell it.
Alright.
Synthetics,
s y n s,
I n t h e t,
I c s.com.com.
And it's just him and his wife and that he does everything by hand.
And he just sculpts these beautiful fucking like real dog type things and it,
it,
it would have been,
it's so perfect.
I wish like him and fleshlight would team up because he has like apart like
these vaginas that,
that,
that you can take out and clean and stuff like that.
And they're kind of like flashlight ish.
But uh,
I could just imagine him putting a real flashlight in that thing because it felt
real.
It looked real and it was so weird seeing Sam Tripoli.
Like after the show was done,
we just,
when we were all hanging out and Sam was just sitting there staring at it like a
little kid looking at boobs for his first time.
And that's what the reaction to everybody that was looking at these things.
I didn't fuck one of these.
No,
we just had a couple of the Christmas party.
That's about 5,000 dude,
it's amazing how life like this,
this,
this was feel real.
You open up the mouth.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's creepy when you're looking at this.
Awesome.
This is amazing how realistic it looks.
I'm Rick,
really shocked.
And here,
here's me and Jay,
me and Jaden cold.
Like we were just raping this one and this one girl.
Yeah cause it's cooling cause he's just pulled down a pants and look at her bio
and stuff.
It was and her bubble comes out so you can put new kinds of buttholes in and
stuff.
It's really weird.
Wow.
They have a bunch of different models.
It's crazy and it's cool cause I was,
I,
I got to talk to them and it's like how do you design them?
And he's like,
well this girl,
you know,
started off with a photo of Megan Fox and then we took the body using this like
famous uh,
you know,
seven crush that website have really?
Yeah.
I feel bad just like that.
We crushed it.
I can't even get on it anymore.
It's fun.
I love when that happens.
But he said anytime you,
uh,
if you want to do a podcast at the ice house,
you'll bring a couple of bites.
We can play around with it and we could meet him,
tell him to get,
get with the flashlight people and come up with a better cooter.
Yeah.
How do you clean that thing out man?
It's odd.
The fleshlight where you unscrew the bottom of it,
the parts that you fuck up a have like this,
uh,
they can pull out kind of like a fleshlight and a refrigerator and like the
button,
what comes out.
The next level is going to be hooking that up to a computer program where you
get like some artificial intelligence said he wants to take the iPhone dock and
the neck of it.
So you can talk to Siri through the iPhone or through them and she'd be like,
hello.
You know whether you can get it to the point where it was like a sexual training
device.
Apparently they're going to come out with some sort of an apple device.
We're Siri communicates to your phone through like something that you were,
so you'll be doing like almost everything through Siri,
you know,
this is the idea to it.
And like you'll press
a button and say,
Siri,
what emails do I have?
And you know,
as Siri,
he gets more and more advanced.
So whatever's in your pocket you'll be doing everything through voice
recognition software.
So series going to control the,
so cereal,
chill the fuck robot.
Well hopefully fuck first the destruct later.
Once we realize that we're fucking there,
their robot daughters,
that's an,
they're going to come after us.
It was one thing.
What's funny is that his version of like that the pussy part,
which was like,
you know,
kind of fleshlight ish.
But it was definitely,
you know,
you could see the quality of flashlight was a billion times better.
What is it in the softness of it is like,
I think it uses maybe a close similar kind of material with it.
But what was different about his is that he actually,
his wife or a girlfriend,
uh,
paint painted like the lips of different color,
you know,
like kind of beat him up a little.
Kind of like really,
really
like the makeup job.
Like catching him tattoo.
Also just catching dick for decades.
The entryways all skidded like fucking Lego to plan keeps coming in for
Atlantic.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just skid elbow.
It's like skid marks on a,
on a fucking pool table.
Fear factor was awesome last night,
man.
It was really interesting to see that the two muscle guys like the,
there was two guys on the show,
like the big buff,
like rip.
The guys had such a hard time early on I was like,
wow,
those two little gay guys is these little muscles.
Not a way to be man.
That's not,
you mean they were saying that there are agile and they move well,
but the bottom line is you're carrying around a bunch of unnecessary muscle.
It's not aiding you in your frame.
The way you move with it requires a lot of fuel.
You get really tired really easily.
Like those guys that have,
like when you see a guy that has an extraordinary amount of muscle on them,
look to someone who like does Jujitsu.
Just someone who does MMA.
You look at that guy and go,
how long can you laugh?
You can't.
Last I'll have to do is grab a hold of you.
All you have to do is engage a guy like that in a fight.
All the gains you might have five to get a hold of them.
I mean there could be really explosive,
all that muscle,
he could really have a powerful punch.
You have to be like really careful.
But if you can get past that and somehow or another managed to get ahold of them
and you know,
just hang on,
just make them struggle to get off you and in 10 15 seconds he's at 30% of what
he was 15 seconds ago.
Like literally.
It's amazing.
Like there were like guys like that are always like one good exertion away from
the heart fucking exploding of their chest.
It's like they have a computer,
like a seller on 300 processor and they got a jacked up to four 25 you're not
supposed to be carrying around that much weight man.
You're just not.
And it's not natural.
It's really hard to do.
You got to put a bunch of shit in your system to make yourself carrying that
much weight.
And most of those guys are non athletic.
You know,
here's a question about the show.
I don't know if you can answer this if,
if I caught something,
but is there a,
did the,
do you guys say like,
Hey,
you guys need to just make fun of each other because that chick last night was
just like,
your ugly face is fucking crazy girl.
Talk some shit about her eyelashes first.
The other girl opened up the gates of hell,
but once she realized she didn't want to fuck with that girl because that black
chick was me and,
and she was getting in her face about it.
You so ugly.
I was Kansas not talking about my eyelashes.
She was like,
you look like a,
the the evil step sister surprised.
There's not more Jerry Springer Shit on that show.
Well,
we keep it to a minimum.
We showed very little of that,
that argument.
But that argument was a big argument.
That shit went on for a while.
I had to calm them down.
I will say,
Hey,
come on.
Listen,
you guys are saying some mean shit.
No,
I shouldn't say you guys cause it was just the girl.
Cause once,
once Tanika started talking shit,
then the,
the girl shut the fuck up quick,
you know,
and how she treated her own husband like well again,
you know the fucking water seeks its own level.
It's like we were talking about it.
I'm like that's not the kind of behavior that you want to hear.
I want to hear in a girl.
But for some dudes they,
you know,
they seek that out and I get it man.
Like I,
you know,
I don't know if you remember it the other day,
aster gave us a bunch of those drinks for drinks and I had,
I had one the other day cause she left one over in the fridge and it was an
orange,
a pineapple or something like that.
And I was drinking it and suddenly in my mouth a bug like uh,
like you know,
lightening bugs,
what those look like,
the ones that aren't lightening bolts but look exactly like a lightening bolt.
So it got in the juice and I was just pouring out and right there I was like
about to Puke.
Like I was like,
I couldn't even imagine drinking a whole fucking milkshake of that shit.
Impossible for me.
So yeah,
you wouldn't be a good candidate and heights.
Impossible for me.
Never.
You don't like to move that much.
So that's not good for you.
Unique factor.
I'm on fear factor now.
In fact,
when you,
I hate to like be morose though,
but when you see people get sick and you see people that are unhealthy,
do you ever stop and think,
man,
eventually I'm going to have to quit smoking cigarettes and actually get my body
in some sort of shape.
Does that ever come up or you just gonna ride that bitch until the wheels fall
off?
Um,
or are you not thinking about it until something breaks on you?
Yeah,
Prague,
more of that.
So I'm probably more Raffi Mang and now I'm going to be like no more marijuana
for me.
I'm like,
wait,
she's something breaks.
You'll get super healthy.
Diet wise.
Weightwatchers I,
you know,
I know you don't believe this,
but I'm at the Diet wise,
I eat really healthy and I,
I'm constantly like doing like juicing and,
and make some,
some healthy things.
But then I definitely,
you know,
I'll have like an olive garden here or there or something like that where I
would just,
you know,
fuck,
I'm just eating like shit going crazy.
But for the most part if you look at my refrigerator,
it's all like,
it's kind of like your refrigerator for the most part.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean I don't eat much though.
That's the problem I eat.
Like last night I ate my first meal at 1:00 AM oh that's like it was all fucked
up and you drink a coffee during the day.
I drink coffee and that pretty much it makes me not hungry for a good five
hours.
I think an important concept applies to the muscle men and applies
to,
everybody actually wrote about it on the Onnit blog.
It's called are you fit enough to survive?
And I think there's an important concept in there,
like take away all of the normal rules.
Let's go back to like a primitive state where you have to chase food for awhile,
maybe run after him a few days and you have to do certain explosive movements in
a fight against an animal or another.
That's,
I answered the question.
It just take a little bit of shoe.
You might fall off the car answer.
Yes.
There's a certain,
the amount of physicality that I think is necessary to maintain a proper mental
balance
either to even for sales.
For some folks,
yes.
For other folks I don't,
I think some people are averse to physical activity.
It,
it reminds them a fucking gym class or whatever and they like it
that hot.
Especially if,
I think especially for men that haunts part of their physical psyche to know
that they wouldn't on a basic primal level be fit enough to survive in a
situation where there weren't all these rules in supermarkets
unless they have now mad Asperger's and they don't know what the fuck is going
on and they're just sitting there counting numbers.
I think everyone's bodies are totally designed different because like you work
out,
you feel good when you work out.
I work out,
I fucking hate him.
Always hate it.
Even when I was like smoking a pack of cigarettes a day,
you eat dog shit all day.
Even when I was a kid,
even in gym class,
even,
even anything.
I hate it.
Oh,
well,
yeah.
I,
you know,
I think you're,
you enjoy it.
Yes.
Well we very different Brian.
I don't know if you figured that out yet.
Especially bodywise man,
you know,
uh,
I don't know how much,
I mean,
look,
I know that the way I'm built is,
a lot of it is genetics because my mom's built like me,
my mom is short and why my mom's bill like a bulldog,
man.
She's,
she's a,
she's not a petite lady by any stretch of the imagination.
She's these big ass wide feet and they were always breaking shoes.
Like she has all these problems with her feet because her feet were always way
too wide for women's shoes.
You know?
I mean it's good if you want like a sturdy brick carrying Sicilian,
you know,
that's what my mom's probably,
her genetics are really good for carrying heavy shit around like back in the
homeland.
But that's like I got those genetics,
you know,
it's like,
it's real clear that like if I don't work out,
I don't trust myself.
I don't,
I don't like the way I resolve issues.
I don't like how quick,
quick my temper is.
I don't like it.
I see that Shit doesn't happen for me.
Aw,
what's also,
but then there's the nature versus nurture thing.
Cause I know the certain amount of his biological,
but a certain amount of it is also,
I've been feeding my body this adrenaline energy potion and my,
my body from the time I was all small boy has been exploding on things,
just smashing things.
And when your body grows up like that,
and it's sort of,
it's sort of like engineer's itself to perform under those balance loads,
you know,
under those extreme loads rather then when it builds up for that and then when
there's no load,
there's no release,
there's no explosion.
There's no,
there's no,
there's no sprints.
There's no smash,
smash,
smash.
All of a sudden he just got all this smashed juice and it's not going anywhere
and somebody cuts you off in traffic.
Fuck you.
I'll fucking spoon my smash juice on you.
You know?
I mean when you,
there's a
lot of people that you see in traffic man,
and they're fucking freaking out and going off on someone.
A lot of those people just need,
they need a physical thing.
They need a physical thing to keep their body in balance.
It's,
the body is not,
it's not even,
everybody's are different.
Everybody has a car,
but for a lot of us,
we're not getting nearly as much smash out as the buyer.
Why?
Really?
It's everybody.
I really think everybody can benefit from it.
The human organism was designed for activity,
not for sitting in front of a computer for nine hours in front of,
you know,
driving home and then sitting and watching TV.
We're not designed that way.
You know,
we're designed to be active and so to compensate,
we have to create particularly intense one hour sessions often.
But because we are going to be sitting in the rest of the time,
it's just the nature of how our jobs are.
But that physical release I think is important,
not just for the body.
Obviously the health benefits of the body are immense.
But for the mind as well.
You know what I've been doing man,
I've been doing light workouts throughout the day instead of like just one big
fucking crazy workout a day.
Um,
I had a back issue.
I kept getting the same muscle pull on my back cause I,
you know,
I would let it get like three quarters of the way healed and then jump back into
Jujitsu class and fuck it up again.
So I had to take like a certain amount of time off.
And when I took time off,
I found out there's a lot of shit that I could still do that wasn't fucking with
me.
So I did it like easily.
So I said,
let me just,
today I'm just going to do a couple sets of Chin ups and a couple sets of dips
and that's it.
Let's see if that fucks with my bag.
No,
it doesn't,
well let me try it tomorrow I'm going to just do a gut and then I started doing
all these things throughout the day.
I would do it like several times a day.
I would do just a few kettlebell exercises,
a few,
and I've found that I was getting like less sore,
but I was getting like strength gains.
It's like it was because when I was doing it over the course of a few months,
I was noticing that when I,
when I do like these little smaller workouts,
like a friend of mine told me that he got the best results on his chin ups when
he would just,
he installed a chin up bar in his house and every day he would just do 10 chin
ups every day.
Not that hard,
you know,
10 Z Z one,
two,
three you'd do 10 and he's done.
But he did it every day and they said after a while I could do 20 and he goes
crazy.
It's just like your body.
It just gets strong at doing that.
And there was never a day where he did it to failure.
He just did it to 10 you know,
but you do it every day and your body goes,
all right,
we need to this fucking ligaments need more blood,
you know,
in fixing and fixing this forearm up.
And then next thing you know his body,
it was almost like no pain but gain,
you know
those bodyweight workouts.
A lot of people who've had a lot of success with that,
I think it was Herschel Walker that did just a ridiculous
push ups.
A lot of people say that Hershel Walker also lifted weights,
that he lies about it.
I don't know.
That's true.
I don't discredit them.
But I do want to put that out there that I did read a lot of crazy shit that he
said.
Like he only drinks like a cup of soup and a fucking low for a couple of pieces
of bread and a salad that's all eat.
And he,
he'll eat once a day and you're like,
okay,
where's all of that mass coming from?
You gotta be numbers involved here.
There's gotta be,
there's how something has to come in and fill that.
That doesn't even make any sense and apparently he wants people to think of
himself as what he is.
He takes a lot of pride in being an athletic freak,
meaning whatever the fuck he is doing and eating and whatever weights he was
lifting.
The guy's 48 years old,
he's an amazing monster shape,
you know,
I mean he's still like a real super athlete,
but you know,
he had like a,
I believe it was trauma induced multiple personality disorder.
I believe it was trauma induced,
you know,
I mean from all the years of playing football and funny a lot of issues,
you know and I think you,
I believe he wrote a book about that so.
So who knows how much he remembers.
There might be one per Herschel's is seat steak all day and fucking doing squats
and Herschel.
It's Herman.
Yeah,
that's her ghost who somebody is working out,
I'll tell you that.
I mean he obviously does the pushups and sit ups and everything else too,
the guys and just,
he's just one of those dudes.
It's just in monster,
monster shape.
He if he ever gotten a flip or a into MMA when he got into football.
If it was around back then,
he might've been like an all time great.
You know,
because you think,
oh my God,
we haven't really seen that yet.
We haven't really seen a guy who was like a soup.
We were seeing it and Jon Jones,
Jon Jones,
we're seeing it.
But before Jon Jones,
we were never seen like some guy who just can learn shit really fast and he's
ridiculously strong and it seems like he's just,
he just has a advantage over everyone he faces when Jon Jones Gravelly Yoda
cheat it and that fucking standing he a teen,
you know like you just knew Liotta was not getting out like his,
his strength,
you know,
his ability to manipulate bodies.
It's really freaky to watch,
man.
He's got like some car I describe it.
It's like he's got like some crazy aunt strength.
We see an ant pick things up effortlessly and picks up a leaf.
And I was like,
I'm a fuck.
Is that again,
just picking up that thing.
If you look at it in relation to it,
to his body,
like my God,
I did it like effortlessly.
More impressive to me was his Ryan Bader fight invaders about us.
He's a great rest of the strong base fucks dude.
He just throws it around.
It was impressive.
Nobody's ever even had him on his back.
I mean,
has anybody,
does everybody,
have you ever seen him?
The hit him a couple of times.
Good.
He does the first time and take a shot.
You can take a shot.
He took some hard shots.
Yeah,
but you know what?
How about he figured out Leo striking.
How about that man?
He had an one tough round and then he came back in a second round him out,
cracked up,
got him to the ground.
He cracked him.
The fucking hard elbow or a punt.
It was a punch.
Her elbows number one.
The first one was like a left hook I think is [inaudible] was coming in time and
then got him to the ground,
smashed him with an elbow and that was basically all she wrote.
It was one elbow,
the auto got up and he was dizzy.
I mean he really said he couldn't focus.
He couldn't see well.
And then John got Ahold of that neck.
You know,
it's like that could be Herschel Walker could have been like one of those guys.
he could,
you know,
there are guys out there,
the human body as we've talking about reports,
they're not equal.
They're just not.
And some of them were getting better and better and better,
you know.
And back in the day,
someone like John Jones would have,
you know,
a few thousand babies cause they should be on some,
the top warrior and some and some,
uh,
yeah,
rotting fourth.
You know,
I read it,
I read a stat,
that gang,
they found
a certain DNA and his y chromosome and Gaviscon is related to 0.5% of the
world's population.
Holy Shit,
5%.
It's like 8% of all the Asiatic people,
but 0.5% of the entire world because of just the amount of people that he had
sex with and his descendants had sex with.
Because the cube Lecan then went into power and he would,
you know,
he ran the Chinese dynasty.
But that kind of effect,
you know,
we won't,
we won't ever see anything like that handling 10% 10% of America will
Chamberlain's DNA.
It's crazy.
But there was something to be sending people decent Gingiss count fucked.
And he didn't even have viagara back then.
He was dead.
He was,
he was planning inside.
He,
I mean,
he was trying to have panguses,
you know,
and then there was no pulling out for Gaviscon.
Yeah,
yeah.
He must've just shot loads and it all day.
All this amazing that that's how people rolled back then.
They just made as many kids as they could.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
not everybody,
but gangs,
Kong,
his boys.
Well,
you know,
just assuming,
right.
We just fucking,
this is,
might be slanders pussies must be so disgusting at the DNA test for Ganga
[inaudible] in particular,
but it probably didn't smell good.
But I think,
I think there's something to be said for that kind of phenomenon because
nowadays the best,
I mean,
gangs,
Khan was not only physically,
you know,
unbeatable as he rose up to the tribes and the Mongol,
step in the plateau.
Nobody could defeat him.
He won all his tribal battles.
But then as a military mastermind,
he was brilliant as far as what he did.
Kind of revolutionized a lot of the theories of warfare.
So very intelligent,
very physically capable.
And by his,
you know,
sexual encounters,
at least the genetics part.
I mean fatherhood was a whole other issue and you know,
the humanity involved in all the ratio.
Here's a great part as far as,
as far as genetically,
and this is how strip clubs were genetically advancing.
You know,
the genetic race probably played some positive part in that.
And that'll never happen again.
Like the geniuses of our world,
like the most amazing people who could genetically speaking purely,
you know,
advance the human race.
They're not having a thousand babies anymore.
They're not even having 10 they're having one or two,
you know.
But really probably what would be beneficial would be if they had tons of
babies.
I mean,
that would really actually further the human rights.
That's what the principal of sexual selection as it happens in the animal
kingdom,
that's how it works.
The biggest,
smartest,
baddest line has the most babies.
You know?
It doesn't happen in man that as we approach some sort of a symbiotic
relationship with computers and technology,
that's inescapable.
The power of the physical becomes less important.
Sure.
It should be the smartest person,
the smartest people,
but have to get that puts the people who have the power now aren't the
physically strongest.
They're the smartest.
They get the money,
the money.
You got to listen to Albert.
Gina,
you get first you get the money,
then you have the power.
Then you get the women.
He didn't say women.
He said pussy,
Bro.
Don't ever clean it up by the foot.
You'll get the money.
Then you'll get the power.
Then you'll get the post.
Well,
maybe he was at Scarface.
Scarface.
Did he say you get the posing or women can't remember?
I've,
I've only seen that once and I have never seen it usually like watching the
Italian movies.
Did you say Italian movies?
Yeah,
I don't really like the Italian movies too much,
Brian.
Oh,
Um,
yeah.
Obviously the smart people are not getting to breathe at the same rate as
Gingiss Kahn did,
but um,
I think people in general are just much smarter and much more aware,
much more in tune than,
than ever before.
But as far as like,
yeah,
like Super Geniuses,
the rain,
the biological race over the technological race,
it seems to me the technological is so fucking far ahead of the biological that
it's almost ridiculous to assume that the biological is ever going to catch up,
whether it's through natural selection or not.
It just seems like technology in the short amount of time that it's been around
has achieved so much momentum and so much innovation.
It's gone so many generations and models greater than what it was when it was
first introduced that it seems like inevitable that that's going to be the big
tip off.
It's going to be a technological innovation sort of a thing that that changes
everything and that the idea that the human body is going to like get good
enough to catch up to that.
I think that's ridiculous.
I think what's going to happen is there's going to be some sort of a large scale
genetic engineering of the human body.
We're too late,
we're too late for the,
we're going to be super people,
Bro.
We're going to be,
we're going to be Thor,
you know,
we're gonna have,
we're gonna have the ability to fly.
And that's creating,
I mean a lot of this technology's moved by genius people,
outliers for a lot of the time and we're also not,
we're,
we're closing down the possibilities for the genius to genius mating that would
naturally occur to create.
That's okay cause a genius can just shoot a load into a cup and make a million
new people from it.
I mean I think that's true.
Maybe then when we figured out how the body is actually created,
how organs are created,
and we've figured out the ability to replicate them,
we're going to be able to figure out the way to make a super body,
you know,
and whether it's through some sort of a genetic manipulation to a person that is
already exist in a certain form,
like in fucking captain America.
When they lock them into that tube and he's Zap him with all that blue shit and
then boom,
he comes out of super person.
I mean that's,
that's not too far away.
Don't you think?
That seems to me like it would be way easier to do then it would be to send
picture through the air and have it go to someone else in Australia or China or
something like that.
That seems to me way more impossible.
Then you can improve a biological unit.
We understand sells,
we understand cell division,
we understand the my mitochondria,
the power plants of the cells.
We understand genetics.
We sort of mapped out the human genome,
our understanding increases and that we shouldn't say our cause.
It's people far smarter than you or I,
but those people,
the people,
the head of it,
their understanding increases every single year.
Their data grows,
their abilities grow.
It's going to reach some point.
Really,
it seems obvious that in the future it's going to reach some point where they're
going to be able to make a fucking superhuman.
Well then the moral spiritual implications as far as whether that's a good thing
or a not a good thing come into play.
Yeah.
It's like who the saw movies of exploring what is,
why is there a good thing at all?
Why is there a bad thing?
Why?
Why does the universe have that even as an option?
Well,
it seems to be that you have to have it in order to,
to inspire movement.
It's almost like you have to have tyranny to,
to really come up with freedom.
You have to like,
you know,
you have to have people pushing you down.
Resistance from the opposite.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean it's,
it seems,
why else would the universe have evil?
I mean all this stuff that exists,
terrible feelings,
horrible things.
You see atrocities.
The guy in Brooklyn who lit the woman on fire and the elevator.
Why?
Why do these even exist?
Why does the universe have this as an option?
If this does seem to be some sort of a mechanism or a program that's moving
towards a very specific and idea or a goal,
something specific is going to,
there's something going on.
There's a process that the human beings involved in just like bees making a
beehive.
There's were involved in some really super complicated process.
I think that,
I agree with that,
but I think that there's,
you know,
that's kind of looking at it kind of a linear curve of progress.
And I think there's some things missing from our evolution and I think our
spiritual base has gotten thrown way off.
And I don't know if that's just the bottom of the religions or think it's
possible that that's natural.
Do you think it's possible that this,
uh,
this lack of a connection to the spiritual,
it was almost necessary to create this technological fucking bizarro world that
we live,
we live in with no conscience and no thinking about the future and no planning.
It's almost like you need a disconnect.
In order for this thing to arise out of the human animal,
we need to become some sort of a technological zombie that just creates and goes
forth and does its bidding.
Does the bidding of the technology,
much like those fucking mushrooms,
I think it's a quarter Samsung washer and it gets inside the fucking ants head
and makes them bloat and the moth.
Yeah.
Well it does it.
The ants too,
right?
Isn't there a fungus that grows it?
I've seen.
I mean that's really what it's like.
It's like we are,
we were infected with technology.
It's almost like technology is what's keeping us from,
from recognizing all these other spiritual realms and keeping us pushing forth
in a certain direction.
Because if you think about it without any technology whatsoever,
they would never be able to stop mushrooms.
They would never be able to stop,
pause.
They wouldn't know anything where anything is.
They wouldn't be able to rescue.
They wouldn't be able to put you in jail.
They wouldn't be able to make laws.
They wouldn't be able to,
you know,
communicate.
It wouldn't have the news,
they wouldn't have,
there would be nothing,
there'd be nothing.
So it would be impossible.
So technology allows people to be suppressed as much as it gives them freedom
and also allows people to be suppressed and stay zombies and keep on the task.
Keep on the task.
I wonder,
man,
I mean,
everything else is natural.
We look at wolves,
wolves is whatever fucked up thing they do where they push the Beta male out and
he's going to starve to death.
We look at,
it's horrible,
but we also know that it's natural and it happens over and over and over and
over again.
And then there's of course a bunch of different scenarios that can take place.
There's
a lot of different things that can happen,
but ultimately they're moving in the same sort of a natural direction every
time.
How did we not know that our lives are not exactly the same way,
just far more complex and intertwined and we're aware of it.
So it gives us this illusion that somehow or another,
this is just a random series of events.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
obviously that's,
that's certainly a possibility,
but I think that I do strongly believe that there were certain situations in
which key people in the wrong moments and key movements in society kind of
debilitated this natural spiritual flourishing that should have grown in
conjunction with the technology.
Maybe technology was always destined to out pace it a little bit
job to eliminate people.
Maybe that's why you're here.
You ever thought about that?
Like this,
this conversation is getting heard about hundreds of thousands of small,
humble,
like a little tiny spark,
a little little,
little,
little hot shoe that gets into the fucking,
the blood screens dream of the world,
a little little virus that spreads out there.
I think that is part of the Movement for change right now.
I think we're out of balance as a society and I think as a world,
and I think we had to get back into it,
probably our indignation is natural.
All the reaction is natural.
Me In a Ron Paul shirt is natural.
It's all natural.
It's,
it's a push into a certain direction and then that's the natural mode,
you know,
of response.
It's what's supposed to do.
And I think it has to happen.
I mean,
a lot of laws have to change.
Things have to be dropped.
I mean,
we have shortcuts to get there.
That's the fucked up thing.
And these shortcuts grow naturally all over the,
all over the world.
And there just happened to be illegal.
And uh,
we gotta we gotta change that and we got to give people the shortcuts but also
the foundation behind it.
I mean,
having somebody just saying,
yeah,
take mushrooms,
go willy nilly.
It's like telling someone to go into the deep jungle and not saying,
hey,
you got,
you got to bring mosquito repellent.
You got to bring this to sign.
Here's some scuba equipment.
[inaudible] good idea either.
I mean,
you still have to,
there's these structures in place and the Shamans of had it figured out,
it's thousands of years of lineage of teaching and how to explore these realms.
Like you say,
it's scuba gear is the perfect analogy.
You know,
don't go deep water diving unless you know exactly what you're doing.
But if you do,
you know,
you can get to these realms that give you direct access to God.
And the reason why religions have pushed against that,
if you have direct access to the all to the universe,
to God,
whatever name you want to put on it,
then you don't need the priests.
And if you don't need the priests,
they have no power.
You know?
So all of these religions came up putting intermediaries in place so that they
could develop these massive power structures using guilt and different
mechanisms to control the people.
And it's a,
I think we got off course and now here's a chance to correct.
Well,
that was John Marco Legros thoughts for the whole creation of the Bible in the
first place.
That it's suppression of information that the original stories were hidden in
these,
you know,
these a little tails in the Bible with all these little hidden clues,
but that really was all about was psychedelic mushrooms.
That these people were just trying preserve this information
when they were captured by the Romans.
It's fascinating if that is the,
the,
the root of it all.
Yeah,
Just a few people trying to keep this experience connection to something else
going,
whether it's real or not,
whether it's real or imagined.
Like I said,
Christianity may maybe not real,
but fucking helps you for sure.
Well,
something's going on.
If something,
if it's fake and yet it still helps.
I know a lot of people believe it or not,
they believe and because they believe they become better,
their lives have been enriched.
So that's an effective tool,
you know?
Sure.
Well,
I mean,
you also have to think,
you know,
obviously there needs to be a place for that and Christianity can fill it,
but is it the best tool to fill that?
Well,
that's the difference between like,
you know,
a lot of people say like,
why would you,
why would you talk bad about someone's ideas,
uh,
when it comes to like Christianity,
but yet you espoused all these ridiculous ideas when it comes to drugs.
Well,
first of all,
it's not all drugs,
it's psychedelics.
And second of all,
just try one.
Just take a deep mushroom trip and tell him we've got something going on.
It's really one of those things where it's a repeatable experience.
You know,
anyone can do it.
You really can.
And then you'll understand what the fuss is all about because it's not as simple
as a hallucination.
It's not,
you know,
there is,
there's definitely some perturbing of your visual senses.
There's your perceptions of the world,
but then there's also a voice and others,
our conversation with something that seems outer worldly that's communicating
with you and some sort of a telepathic way.
And there's always a deep insight into how your life works and a really clear
illumination of all the issues that you've got going on,
which is like why would there be an inexperience?
It's both humbling and enlightening and guiding and why?
Why would there be that?
And is it just in your imagination,
you know,
is it really,
is it that simple?
Is it that sample or is it,
is this how a life form community?
I mean,
there's two ways to look at it.
Yeah,
there's the what is actually happening away.
But then there's the simple pragmatic,
you know,
effect of how it affects people who take it.
And overwhelmingly the people who have taken these in the right with the right
intent and the right setting have these mystical experiences that change their
life for the positive.
So whatever you're accessing pragmatically,
it's a positive benefit.
It feels this void defined the mystic,
you know,
obviously it myself and you believe that there is something else out there that
you're accessing for sure.
And the traditions do as well.
But either way,
just on a purely pragmatic approach,
it's having positive benefits on positive studyable.
The Johns Hopkins University did the,
you know,
the recent magic mushrooms study,
they did improve long term psychological health.
I mean this is,
you know,
it's a legit university.
They're coming to this conclusion after doing tests on people.
The point there is they say they found a sweet spot.
We can optimize the positive persistent effects and avoid some of the fear and
anxiety that can occur and be quite disruptive.
Says Lead Author Roland Griffiths,
professor of behavioral biology at Hopkins.
So what he's essentially saying is what everyone's been saying.
You need a Sharman.
Sharman doesn't just like throw you out into the fucking woods,
but gives you the correct dose and allows you to achieve this,
this state of oneness.
You know,
that whatever it is,
a state,
let's just call it bliss.
So we take out all the woo woo,
let's take,
let's just call this state of an enhanced experience that is a s a psychedelic
bliss,
bliss mixed with self reflection and critical hands and Aaron's very fair,
very fair,
honest and,
and uh,
uncomfortable at times.
Sure.
You know,
and that's a hallmark of all psychedelic experiences that this is the,
the personal reflection in eating marijuana.
He didn't.
Marijuana is one of the most personal reflecting things you can do.
That's why a lot of people hate it.
You know,
they hate when they go too deep when they fuck up and eat a Brownie and like you
bitch and then they sit down and freak out about the fucking world as much as
you think you are looking at the whole thing.
I bet you're not looking at it all because you can't,
in order to get in your fucking car and get on the four oh five every day and
drive into downtown La.
The only way you can do that every day as if you compartment,
compartmentalize your thinking.
And if you're,
if you're thinking about the,
the very structure of the universe,
you thinking about you,
you get subatomic particles,
you start thinking about waves and string theory and,
and craziness and what is cells and biology and the different organisms that
live in your body and the healthy bacteria consume and yogurt and fucking acid
off the list.
And like,
what's going on here?
What do you can't?
There's not enough room for that,
right?
You can't process all that shit.
So you got to put your blinders on,
but then they eat that browning.
It all just blast into focus.
You know,
it feel your heartbeat seems weird.
It seems tired.
The best analogy,
right?
The
best analogy I heard was that,
you know,
taking psychedelics is like a banquet for the spirit.
You know,
it takes a while to prepare,
takes a lot.
It's very rich.
Take some time to digest.
You can't do that every day.
But you know,
and what fills the void,
you know,
eating dinner in this analogy is meditation and just doing a little bit,
it could be yoga,
it could be 10 minutes in your house,
but actually finding that point of stillness in our lives,
that's dinner.
And then the banquet is when you get to really go into the void and bring back
some knowledge and some different experiences.
But I think that would be the one thing.
If we could create one rule,
and if I could say I had omnipotent power,
the one rule would be that there would be some shot,
you know,
shamanistic tradition that had a coming of age,
custom ceremony and an in the world in which when you came of age as this as a
society,
you know,
you had a psychedelic mystical experience with the train guide,
with your peers and with your elders and had this community experience only,
even if it was only just one.
So you got to experience and taste.
That's something else that's holy,
other than just yourself and kind of transcend your own ego even for one
evening.
And I think that would make single handedly the most difference as far as change
in society.
You know that one coming of age ritual in which,
you know,
they got to experience that.
I think that would be it.
Unless someone made it like now
you are a warrior
and you fucking take your short and go out in the world and try to fucking cut
down your kingdom.
Yeah,
no,
that couldn't be like that.
But the Shamans don't.
You know,
they never,
no,
I wouldn't say never.
Obviously there's different Shawmut's,
but the tradition is not in that.
It's in transcending the ego and all.
A lot of those kind of warmongering mentalities is very ego driven.
Like,
I will stomp you because I am strong.
You know,
you don't get that from the psychedelic experience.
I mean,
you could get that endorsement.
Yeah,
they got it from Anita Musk area.
They would.
Zucker,
yeah.
You can certainly channel it into some very invincible,
aggressive states.
Especially if that's like your reality.
That's what you,
you know,
your Wa,
you want Odin to guide you to victory,
man.
I mean,
your,
your reality is not,
there are no vacation homes.
Okay.
For the fucking Vikings,
there is no Disneyland resort that you can take the kids,
you know,
it's about cutting people's heads off where they cut your heads off.
Right.
That's about storming.
The beach isn't taken all the women.
And so that's what he wants some mushrooms to help them out with this.
There was no other way to live,
you know?
Were there any,
you know,
pacifist vikings?
No,
they didn't survive.
Like they didn't make babies.
None of that going on back then.
Bitch,
you there for one reason to make little baby Brock Lesnar's yeah,
that's it.
That was the goal.
Yeah.
I think,
I think mushrooms in particular allow you,
I,
you know,
I believe that there's kind of two energetic forces out there and they're not
good and they're not evil ones.
Just,
you know,
you can call it the dark or,
and call it the light,
but once more really the primal side of,
of life,
it's that kill or be killed.
It's that kind of savage animal,
a dominant side,
and that has a certain energy that has some destruction elements to it.
But it's all,
like you said,
it's all part of the same thing.
You can in some people know,
some people don't have it and some people are really purely intellectual and
they're just not,
they're not connected to the physical,
but their intellectual.
It's like off the fucking charts.
And I think that's also a part of this big crazy puzzle is it?
There's a you and there's a mean,
there's a Brian and then you know,
there's sure it's like that old song.
It takes him to Africa and the people,
I mean,
it sounds so stupid and ridiculous and simple,
but it really does.
I mean in order to accomplish this greater goal,
just bizarre,
you know,
multicultural,
Uber,
complex civilization,
it really does require almost every conceivable personality,
all work.
I still think that people should strive for internal balance.
I think that leads to the biggest happiness.
I think access both.
If you're pulled towards that,
if you feel like,
you know it's missing in your life,
you know,
and for a lot of people that is the case.
A lot of people feel,
a lot of people are very unhappy.
You know,
a lot of people do not feel fulfilled.
I feel very lucky that everything I enjoyed that I do for,
you know,
for my,
in my life.
I enjoy these things.
I enjoy every podcast I do.
I enjoy all of my friends except Saturday,
Saturday just kind of sucks.
But that wasn't your fault.
Shit happen man.
You just,
you can't get Darryl right in a porn star in one room and expect fucking sparks.
Um,
you know,
I,
and if you can figure out a way to do that,
to find whatever it is you do that you really get satisfaction of with,
whether it's carpentry or whether it's,
you know,
a painting,
pictures and whatever the fuck it is,
then really is number,
like one of the most important things.
And then no cons.
Have a no rule,
just no cons.
Don't be a cunt.
Just stop it.
You know when people get mad at me on the message board,
cause I keep fucking pinking people in banning people.
The way my message board is set up on the Joe rogan.net is there's a bunch of
moderators.
All of them I know personally,
or at least I know I'm online and they're all really cool and they don't want
you to being a Douche bag.
It's really simple.
If you act too annoying,
you're trying,
trying to fucking hard you.
You stumble in and Piss off people,
you get conti,
you just get moved to the stupid room and the stupid room.
You get a pink name and you know,
and now everybody knows you fucked up.
You either acted like an asshole or you were rude or you got annoying.
What are the fucking has?
You're not being cool,
you're not enhancing things.
And for some reason people think that you're supposed to buy by giving them free
speech.
You're allowed Lao them in near little cyber room,
allow them to be cunts like people have mistaken free speech for you can be a
client with no repercussions like,
yeah,
what about free speech?
It's like,
this isn't speech.
You're just cunty.
It's all you were allowed to talk,
but I don't have to listen.
I shut you off.
I don't want you around.
Do you not understand that you're an unpleasant vibe?
It's not.
No one's stopping you from starting your own message board,
no one starting you.
But what they're saying is in a cyber home,
you're not welcome anymore because you're annoying.
Cause he come over and you bring a bad vibe and people for whatever fucking
reason,
because they're so entitled with this sense of anonymity and this,
this,
this unnatural way of behaving that people have because there's no social
repercussions.
The norm is to be country.
The norm is to say bitchy shit that would make me tell you to get the fuck out
of my party.
And you think you could just do that and they think they could just do it and
get away with it and you're an asshole if you call him.
I'm like,
dude,
just stop talking about me.
Stop being a dick.
Go Away.
Bye Bye.
Imagine having a party and some guy comes over and just criticizes you.
You know everything you're saying and you know it says you're half retarded and
some of your ideas like,
oh,
okay,
get out of my fucking house,
Dude.
Just go.
You.
Obviously
there's other ways to communicate you fuck and you're thinking that there's only
one way because you've been doing it this way for so fucking long.
You actually feel entitled to be a cunt to treat it like it's a house.
Would you come over someone's house and you're meeting them and would you
communicate with them like that?
If you would,
I would kick you out.
It's really that simple.
Don't think you can come into my cyber house and not get kicked out for being
annoying.
Don't make me boot ballet you.
Oh Shit.
I just dish.
Have you been booed blade?
Is there an update?
I haven't seen.
I haven't seen any of their,
what they call that bublé denial.
Dude,
I haven't seen a goddamn thing.
It's true life.
No,
I don't want this for a fact.
That last night I had to,
I had
to tweet it and I was tweeting live.
Oh yeah.
I was wondering if you were doing that for them.
I'll do it.
It's,
it's fun,
but I can't,
I can't give away spoilers.
Right.
I have to make sure that,
uh,
everything I'm saying is like MMM,
no,
no spoilers.
Yeah.
Just gotta protect information from the people speak when you were watching it
east coast time.
How the fuck is that?
Because you have direct TV.
Oh,
I just know shit though.
Y'All dog.
I know people I know to hook that shit up.
I see.
Um,
I wanted to bring something out.
Why while uh,
Aubrey's here and yes,
his name used to be Chris.
If you go back and go,
man,
they used to be a second thoughts as the guy looked just like that lock.
No second thoughts.
It's actually finally got to the point where,
you know,
Chris sounds weird to me,
really it's not that many people that can pull off changing their fucking name,
you know,
and having us not make fun of it.
We had to make fun of a little,
I guess you got a little of it,
but it ain't,
it ended up,
I still got a few of the like,
well,
who's that girl?
Aubrey was Texas,
I would imagine.
Yeah,
go named Aubrey.
Yeah.
Do you ever wear a beaded bracelets?
Do you ever do that?
No,
because usually I do have,
I do you have like wooden beads is a shells.
Oh,
isn't not a John Half Ron joke is it?
Hey,
I wanted to talk,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
we know each other originally from the flashlight.
A lot of people might not know that.
And then we're sort of in business together and on it and uh,
make an Alpha brain and shroom tech sport.
And um,
I,
by the way,
I love that I fucking Trump type that stuff,
that shit before Jujitsu.
It's great for working out,
but this is your beat 12 in that too.
There is,
how much be 12 methylcobalamin.
There's um,
2000 micrograms in there.
That's a good amount.
But the,
but the Methylcobalamin is a different type of B12 and the Cyanocobalamin,
a Cyanna Cobell and extra creates a molecule,
a cyanide when it's released into the body.
But methylcobalamin is called Methyl B 12.
A lot healthier for the body and a lot better.
But a lot of people take,
you know,
like an athlete that gets an injection time,
that's,
you know,
tens of thousands of micrograms would be 12.
So it's water soluble,
uh,
releases any excess,
just releases through urine.
So the body will utilize what it can and then,
uh,
and then just pee out the rest.
And the quarter steps.
Mushroom was first used by Chinese athletes.
Is that who,
uh,
they figured it out first Chinese,
but they figured it out 2000 years ago.
The courthouse steps,
the herdsmen in northern Tibet and China,
they're an extremely high altitudes.
And now up there and those altitudes,
the herds and the people get very sluggish.
And they noticed that when a certain type of mushroom was available and on the
ground and the herds would eat it,
the herds would become particularly active and there would be moving around.
They'd have more endurance,
they'd be able to push them harder and they'd be playing more.
And so the,
you know,
back in the day,
that was your biggest cue if you were just a person kind of looking around.
So they took a look at these and they tried them themselves and found the same,
same results.
And what we know now is that the court accepts mushroom.
It's actually a symbiont to the ghost moth,
which is the host for this,
uh,
for the mushroom.
And what they believe that it does is the same thing that it does in people and
in other animals and ingest it.
It increases the oxygen utilization and cellular energy of the animal,
of the moth itself to allow the moth in this extremely high altitude plane to be
able to fly better,
to be able to fly longer and actually survive and adapt.
And then when the moth dies,
the quarter's hubs mushroom actually springs out of it.
And so the first people to discover it in form of like real athletic competition
was um,
coach Meyer and the Chinese Olympic team today,
shroom tech and then you die on mushrooms going to grow your fucking head.
I'm serious,
man.
Sports is it like those,
those uh,
those ants,
it's like those ants and fucking in the,
in the,
uh,
is it the Amazon?
Whatever jungle it is,
where those,
uh,
those ants get infected by spores and then those spores explode other fucking
head and contaminate the other hand.
These are dead and dried.
Otherwise,
you know,
it could be possibly no,
it really,
these are dead and dried and take their dead and dried.
Then what is the,
uh,
the benefit?
Where's the benefit coming from
coming from what's inside?
What's inside the mushroom?
There's a lot of available raw identizine,
which is what is,
uh,
an important factor in ATP,
ADP,
ADP.
So don't go grown your own cordyceps mushroom and just eating them.
Well,
we'll kill all that anyways,
but,
but it does,
but it's a different mushroom.
France.
Cordyceps is only found in the north,
in the high regions of,
of Tibet.
And China and it was actually the most expensive nutritional compounds in the
world.
For a while it was getting up to over $20,000 a kilo.
Holy Shit steps mushroom at some point because it's really hard to grow.
It's impossible to grow really until,
until they could only wild cultivated from these mosques.
It was very difficult until a Aloha nutritional,
the the company that we get it from doctor John Holiday,
he made some real advances in medicine that allowed him to cultivate it and in a
competitive substrate that allows the quadriceps to grow and be very effective
in a,
in a cultivated state.
Otherwise they had to explain the competitive aspect of it cause that's really
fucking fascinating.
Yeah.
So they grow it in like a brown rice kind of compote substrate.
And what they found is it mushrooms have to compete for a variety of things when
they come upon a log or any kind of different environment with Marin.
Um,
depending on what's out there,
they will put out anti-competition compounds,
which actually both strengthen their own,
their own species and also eliminate the other species.
So if there's a bunch of bacteria,
they'll excrete certain certain things to work.
The bacteria that's trying to get at the decomposing log.
But if there's other mushrooms,
there's certain anti-competition compounds available in those mushrooms that's
going to allow the mushroom to actually thrive.
And some of those anti-competition compounds are some of the bioactive compounds
that are found in the mushrooms.
Wow,
that's fucking bad ass.
But putting them in a competitive environment,
it makes them make more strong,
stronger in the court,
accepts you get more rod adenosine and the oxygen is another really
cool thing.
And,
and that,
that's very easy to test actually.
Cause you can actually take a mask and the oxygen level is normally 20% and you
breathe it out at 13% and then you put the mask on and after taking cordyceps
for two weeks,
you'll come out and oxygen you intake is still at instill at 20% but you're
breathing out at 8% which was one of the studies that they show.
So that's a 50% increase,
roughly 40% seems like that every night he would have to take it then.
Is that really possible?
That seems like too high.
I don't notice it that high.
I don't,
I don't feel like it's that high one.
I don't feel like I have 50% more endurance.
Well that's just oxygen utilization though.
That's not endurance.
It's not measuring the actual endurance capacity utilization should be a huge
part of that.
Shouldn't be.
It should be a big part.
And that study that study's been out,
it's actually posted on the site.
Uh,
other studies have shown,
you know,
varying different degrees,
but always oxygen utilization is a key.
And also adenosine,
um,
providing increased ATP synthesis versus ADP.
The biggest boost that I ever gotten during swatched when I had my nose fixed
because my nose was all fucked up and talks and sign.
I couldn't get any air through it.
It was a mouth breather.
And then once I got my nose fixed,
I was like literally like I got a 20% bump in my party.
It's a big difference.
It's amazing.
You know,
that was the most amazing,
obvious,
uh,
thing that I realized.
But this is a fucking close second.
When I,
when I have like real hard workouts man,
you know,
especially like Jujitsu class,
like you know,
I uh,
I rode for the first time in a while last night and I,
I rolled like,
you know,
deep into the class like a lot of times,
you go five or six guys and you just don't want to do it anymore.
You've just done.
But this like gets me one extra role.
I feel like it's not easy but it gets,
we one extra role and at the end of it where I'm like,
wow,
I feel like I feel all right,
100%.
It gives you a boost but it doesn't give me that cracked out red bull.
There's no,
there's no stimulants in it.
So surrounding the quarter steps,
which is providing cellular energy versus glandular energy,
glandular energy is basically tricking your body to release adrenaline.
That's where caffeine and all these things are doing basically re releasing more
adrenaline.
So you feel like you have energy,
but your actual cells,
which are still using the ATP cycle to produce energy,
don't have any extra energy.
So you push harder because you think you have the crush your adrenals and you
crush your adrenals.
This had been,
James was told by his doctor,
he had to stop drinking coffee.
Yeah,
it's killing us.
Just pushing that button over and over again until the button just doesn't have
as much to get out and just turns to a leathery sad.
This is operating on a totally different mechanism and that's why you get that
kind of physical burst.
It,
it's uh,
it's subtler than people.
People were used to taking it.
Oh,
explode.
You know,
they might be like,
oh,
this shit sucks.
That's a good question.
I'm wanting to ask you about this.
I liked that.
Jack Three d I liked that stuff before I work out.
Can I take the two of them together?
And just literally there are no negative repercussions doing it.
They're doing completely different things.
So,
you know,
Jack Three d makes you fucking,
you just feel like you got some energy to good.
And by the way,
we have no affiliation with Jack Three d use,
whichever nitric oxide supplement you enjoy.
But a buddy of mine told me about Jack Three d is like,
dude,
I like this stuff.
And I'd started taking,
I was like,
give you a little boost.
Yeah.
You know what else is great to Beta Alanine Beta Alanine.
Dr Ulous told me about this,
um,
uh,
you was a famous sports doctor and he said,
this is one of the few things that he's noticed like over the past few years,
supplements that he finds to be really legit as far as like a muscle building,
like a muscle recovery.
And he's,
he's found that he makes a big gains of this stuff or,
or quicker gains.
She has used to and he's pretty in tune with his body.
That's another thing about this,
a shroom tech stuff.
I think you have to be in tune with your body.
And you know,
when people ask me like,
Hey,
what should I buy this stuff?
Should I buy that shroom tech stuff?
Like do you work out how to,
how hard you work?
If you don't work out really hard,
save your money.
It'd be nice just for the energy boost.
So instead of having Starbucks everyday.
Yeah.
But Starbucks different energy.
A different kind of,
once you start working out,
that's when you really start to feel it.
Yeah,
I get that.
Starbucks.
Do you mean when you hit a fucking,
you know,
uh,
a [inaudible] coffee at Starbucks and you two sips in it.
You fucking love everything.
Pukka I want to go fucking paint my car.
You know,
you get like almost like a meth crank.
Sort of like really excited feeling to it.
You don't ever get that with shroom tech Trent.
Oh my God.
It's 30 ounces and it's the size of your stomach.
Dude.
You're going to die.
I do one of those a day that's going to Jack your whole system,
man.
Um,
sleep.
Yeah,
you're,
you gotta be,
you must be massively addicted.
The other stream tech product though,
everybody.
Everybody should definitely.
And what is the difference?
What's the,
the,
the stuff,
insurance,
a whole different set of mushrooms.
So from,
you know,
from Aloha medicinals,
Dr John Holidays,
his kind of flagship product is this product called Iowa Immune,
which takes certain elements of these mushrooms that he grows together and the
substrate,
um,
it's actually a very specific part of it and they're called triple righthand
helix polysaccharide Beta glucans and what these particular mushrooms do and
their president,
Chaga mushrooms in particular,
the strong quantity.
I take that.
Yeah.
And uh,
what they do is they actually trigger a,
an innate response from the immune system.
So in the body's natural immune system,
the gut is responsible for a lot of the,
you know,
natural killer cells that actually fight all the pathogens and entering
bacteria,
viruses,
cancer cells that are shed.
And what happens at an early age for us is with all the antibiotics that are in
our water,
and then,
you know,
that we take,
we ended up killing scores of these probiotic bacteria in our stomachs.
So they are no longer available to create the amount of immune cells that can go
attack any invading pathogens that get us sick all the time.
So we're at a natural disadvantage what the,
and they've done a ton of studies on this io immune.
They're using it in Q and a at the same time as cancer patients getting
treatment for chemotherapy at the same time that,
uh,
hepatitis B patients are getting treatment with the [inaudible],
which is a viral,
um,
uh,
prescribed pharmaceutical viral therapy and having,
you know,
dramatically positive results in combination with other treatments because it's
raising the body's natural immune system.
And how it does it is these triple righthand Beta Glucan polysaccharide
molecules,
which are unique
to these mushrooms.
Um,
they are recognized by the body as foreign elements,
but,
and so the body mounts up their charge of innate and natural killers,
these B t cells and different killer cells and basically builds an army to deal
with this.
That's actually a benign threat.
So there's a cardboard army coming at them and they have a hundred nukes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So that's crazy.
They're mounting,
they're rallying and they're creating more immune cells that are capable of
handling actual threats.
And is that taxing on your system at all?
No.
It's what the,
the system is supposed to have more natural killer cells in it naturally,
innately.
And,
and as I was mentioning,
I think you might've been rummaging,
you know,
doing something,
but um,
what happens is when the gut gets all that probiotic bacteria gets killed from
all the antibiotics in our different foods,
we water in different drugs,
they're not able to produce an adequate quantity.
So we're actually at an immune deficits and naturally do antibiotics actually
make it from a cow into your body when you,
when you eat a cow,
the who believe so proven.
I don't know if it's been proven.
That's,
that's kind of a,
but that's kind of the theory that goes on.
And I'd have to do some more research on it.
Makes Sense.
I know water with,
you know,
they say that there's stuff in the water,
but everybody who hasn't taken courses of heavy antibiotics,
all of us now,
and when you do that,
you kill the probiotics.
And what moves in instead in its place is yeast.
And the analogy that I use,
it's like once you get crabgrass in your lawn,
you know,
you can sprinkle more seed.
Like by taking kind of probiotics,
you can sprinkle more seed over the lawn,
but it's not going to kill the crab grass.
They've taken up an occupied that spot.
So we're operating,
you know,
our natural immune cell producers are not there in the quantity that they should
be that they used to be.
And so,
you know,
really taking these particular mushroom,
uh,
stimulators is one way that we can actually build our army back up so it can
fight off.
Not only the little things,
a little colds,
the little flus,
the little stuff that we just kind of deal with.
But also,
you know,
a lot of the big things start small,
different cells shed different mutated made itself.
A dendritic cell should be around to just say,
oh,
that thing's fucked up.
I'm going to eat that.
But a lot of times that's,
and that doesn't happen just because we don't have the available immune innate
response to challenge that.
So shrimp tech immune combines that patented,
you know,
the proprietary compound io immune,
which has been well studied in,
in a bunch of the studies,
combines it with Chaga mushroom,
which is also another great mushroom that,
uh,
has a lot of the same triple righthand helix Beta glucans.
Uh,
it also has Estrella NAIC acid,
which comes actually from the birch tree in which it is found.
So wild harvested Chaga is actually better for you than cultivated Chaga.
There was a dude who had some whole video is pushing chocolate.
There's,
when I first started doing it,
some crazy guys tattooed all over.
His whole body was weird,
like different inks and shit.
So it was a mushroom specialist,
but he had one,
he had a Chaga mushroom that he's holding up and it's like this big fucking
crazy looking thing,
man.
It doesn't look like a mushroom.
It looks weird,
man.
It looks like a,
a hunk of a log or something.
Right?
Yeah.
So weird looking at lusher.
This yeah.
Grows,
you know,
only
on the birch tree naturally in the wild.
Mushrooms are closer to animals and the art of plants.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a very interesting species.
We're fucking thing around forever.
Organism in the world is a mushroom colony that lives in the Pacific northwest
and Emma,
Nita Barbosa I think is the species name of that colony.
Is that what it is?
The conference 37 acres,
giant organism that like is in the ground.
You know,
it's really nuts.
It is Jim.
Imagine at 37 Acre being,
I mean yeah,
you could take chunks of it and make other beings,
you can import them other places,
but essentially it's one,
one sort of a being and it's like a network,
you know,
if,
if mushrooms really do have intelligence,
you know like when you eat well,
you know there's a lot of people that believe that plants have a certain
intelligence,
they don't just don't have the ability to communicate,
but if these mushrooms have an ability,
somehow our ability to communicate because they're all connected like that and
they have this intelligence that can communicate with each other.
Like that's some incredible like information superhighway that's in the forest
up there.
Yeah,
it sounds very avatar,
but it's very hot.
Yeah,
it does look avatars based on a lot of like Hippie dippie woo ideas about,
you know,
the,
the intelligence of plants.
But I've talked to people,
I have to research whether or not it's real,
but like plants can tell when they're around certain persons who have harmed
them.
You know,
someone comes along and chops a fucking plant with an ax and then that person's
near the plant.
You can register it on a plant.
Don't know if there's some interesting studies on the music influencing the
growth of plants,
like death metal versus classical real asco music.
Yeah.
There's some really interesting studies on that.
How nobody likes,
it's not even the plants.
Even plants,
they live in dirt and they'd survive on cow shit,
but they have better taste than death metal.
Something about that energy that deal with Alpha brain is a,
is a very fucking polarizing subject I've found on the Internet.
And so it's a fascinating thing,
man.
MMM.
Nootropics.
You know,
we've been talking about nootropics on my message board for like the longest
time and I've been experimenting with them for years,
but until we started getting in the business of actually selling them,
I didn't realize how country people can deal with this things.
But,
um,
one of the criticisms,
and I think there's some legitimacy.
This is the way it's marketed and one of the things is,
um,
and you know,
it's not on purpose.
I don't think,
uh,
I think what the way you set it up was you just trying to be enthusiastic about
it.
And the problem with somebody once said that,
uh,
I forgot where I wrote this.
I,
I've,
I believe I read it today,
something,
it might've been on the message board,
but it was about in first impression that it's very difficult to take that back.
And once you create something and you put something out there and people get an
idea who you are,
it's very difficult for them to correct that and normalize and come.
So you have to be really careful what your initial first thing is.
And one of the things that we get criticized with is this Guy Steve Novella,
who's,
um,
I dunno,
some super smart dude.
There's some,
what do you know what,
what,
uh,
yeah,
he was Ashley's from,
uh,
thought it was,
yeah,
maybe perhaps Yale University.
He's a,
he doesn't say,
but essentially what he's,
he's criticizing the way that the,
um,
that the way that it's marketed,
the way there's a studies were put out there.
Yeah.
You know,
I think looking at that criticism I think,
and any variety of criticism,
I mean,
I think,
uh,
you have to just learn and adapt and get better from it.
And I think he,
I think he has a very skeptical mindset,
which I think in a lot of avenues is very positive.
But I think,
you know,
it can be overdone.
He actually runs a few shows called,
you know,
the skeptic,
um,
some skeptic hour or some variety of different things.
So he has that kind of framework in mind.
But you know,
some of his criticisms are fair,
you know,
really,
and what,
you know,
taking that criticism and you know,
a lot of criticism from the board that even if it's very negatively put a
applying that has helped,
I believe,
you know,
us to become better,
at least myself as a person to become better as far as marketing that.
And you know,
there's certain areas that you got to shore up and you gotta be tighter and you
got to be better and really try and present information so that just people have
as much information as possible can make educated decisions.
I mean,
the,
the many people who take Alpha brain and about amazing results,
you know,
that is,
that will be evidence for,
you know,
for a lot of people to give it a try.
And you know,
if they don't like it,
then,
uh,
then they can get their money back and they don't even have to send the bottle
back in.
We'll give you your money back on your first bottle without even sending it in.
Some people have,
um,
a lot of people have experienced positive results.
I S I personally experienced positive results.
I use it every day.
I enjoy it.
I think it makes a difference.
When I don't take it,
I feel it.
Um,
it's not a huge difference,
but it's something,
it's a clarity.
I believe in it 100%.
And I've,
I've,
I've really like,
um,
just like with the quadriceps mushroom supplement,
I work out a lot.
I eat really healthy.
I know for the most part what's going on with my body and I feel I can feel
differences.
I know when I'm tired,
you know,
because of too much,
not enough sleep,
too much work,
whatever.
I know when things are in sync and when things are in sync and I've taken out
for brain,
I feel boost.
I feel a difference.
Um,
but other people know,
other people don't.
Not only do they not feel something,
they get sick.
Like I've talked to people online and there's too many of them to ignore it,
but they say it made him feel like shit.
You know,
what does that,
I,
there's a certain sensitivity to pursue serrato which is creating an
acetylcholine boost.
And,
um,
you know,
that's something that,
that we're addressing and in future form and it's not,
it will actually make somebody feel potentially,
and this is our only,
you know,
this is our best estimation of what's happening,
but it seems like the case when they take too big of a dose,
uh,
the Acetylcholine levels get to get basically two high end.
I tell people,
take one,
start off with one.
Yeah,
it's best to be conservative.
I mean,
this is no wonder without food,
what do you,
how do you recommend it
meal?
Especially if you're on a,
especially if you're on taking one,
you know,
maybe a very,
not a completely dead empty stomach,
but you should,
if you pile it on to a giant cheeseburger,
you know,
you've got so much stuff going on,
it's going to be very difficult and it might just get pushed through.
But does it enhance its absorption using food?
Um,
no.
It's just an enhances its tolerability too.
To a certain degree.
It doesn't bother me at all.
I take it on an empty stomach.
I do too.
But it's,
it's,
you know,
some people that may actually enhance the effects.
So until you get,
until you get kind of comfortable with it,
I think definitely best to be conservative,
invest to take some breaks to,
you know,
start with one.
Um,
see how you feel and you don't have to take it every day.
What percentage of people do you think are,
have a sensitivity to it?
It's a very small percentage,
a small percentage.
I mean,
overwhelmingly the response has been positive and we get that.
We get those people,
all those people,
you know,
contact us for their money back.
We give them their money back and it's a very,
very small percent.
I mean,
our,
that rate I would have to say is less than one out of every 200.
But you know,
the,
it is,
it is definitely a bummer and it's something we want to address and at least,
especially by telling people to start conservative with their dosage and then
taking a look at,
um,
at the Hoop Herzliya Serrata and we actually have,
you know,
have some things in mind for the proper,
proper balances of see,
oh Perseus Durata to GPC calling to make sure that those are going to be better
tolerated,
um,
throughout the future of Alpha brain.
So,
you know,
hopefully just like I said,
you learn and a,
you try and improve and be the best product for everybody.
I think for some people,
you know,
it won't work.
And for some people,
uh,
they may not,
they may have an adverse reaction,
but,
you know,
the overwhelming majority is spoken very positively and it's,
it's great to hear that feedback from,
uh,
from the product is one of the dudes who's on the message board.
Uh,
his name is James MMA,
very bright guy,
and he's a,
one of the skeptics are critics.
And you had a conversation with him about,
uh,
he'd asked you,
you know,
how,
how it works improving cognitive function.
Like what the fuck could does?
And we,
you said the,
basically that Alpha brain is designed to provide the precursors and raw
nutrients necessary to raise levels of important neurotransmitters such as
Acetylcholine and dopamine and Gaba.
Now,
how is that done?
What is,
what does it,
what's the mechanism that allows it to raise these levels of these important
neurotransmitters?
Well,
it's just depends on,
uh,
which neurotransmitter you're talking about.
But if you're talking about acetylcholine and we come at that in two fronts.
The GPC,
Coleen is one of the raw nutrients involved in the production of Acetylcholine.
So by providing the more of the raw ingredient,
it allows the body to produce more.
And then who Percy.
Serratus is coming at a different angle.
That's actually a inhibiting.
Um,
it's actually inhibiting the,
the amount of Acetylcholine at the body breaks down.
So it's providing more acetylcholine from a kind of a different angle by
actually creating a surplus of what you currently have rather than the,
than the GPC calling,
which is creating,
um,
more raw material to provide the acetylcholine and the other,
the other neurotransmitters fall more along the lines of the GPC Coleen,
where you're just providing the raw nutrients to allow the body to take the
steps to produce those raw nutrients and turn those into the neuro transmitters.
And this is actually another thing.
This is the foundation of the new mood formula,
which is providing,
you know,
there's four major neurotransmitters as identified by Dr Braverman.
Um,
and the other one is serotonin and five HTP is the direct precursor to
Serotonin.
And in the same way in that product,
uh,
by providing the raw nutrient that the body then converts into Serotonin,
you create a surplus of serotonin without having to take,
um,
any other kind of prescription drugs.
And there's actually a cool study on that front to illustrate the point.
There's actually been a bit more research on the serotonin effect because of the
massive amounts of Ssri and prescription drugs in that field.
Uh,
there's been a good amount of study done on five HTP.
Dr Pollinger had a study in 1991 where he compared five HTP to fluvoxamine,
which is a Ssri.
And the study showed that the SSRI stands for selective Serotonin reuptake
inhibitor and that's like Zoloft and Prozac.
Paxil.
Yup.
And um,
and basically it showed that the five HTP dosage,
which was a hundred milligrams a few times a day,
was equal to the fluvoxamine and of efficacy,
but far out paced it as far as tolerance,
just because the body was able to go through its natural process and create more
of its serotonin and a,
the study turned out extremely positively.
The problem is that there is no patent available on five HTP.
So you know,
everybody can go out and get it.
They can buy our product,
they can buy anybody else's product and get those similar effects.
So
I found out about five HTP for my friend Neil Brennan and a Neil told me he's on
it.
And he loves it.
It makes him feel good.
But Neal's also on an antidepressant.
Well,
his doctor told him to get off the five HTP and stay on the antidepressant
because he said taking the five HTP is like taking a second antidepressant.
So I said to him,
I was like,
whoa.
Have you ever thought about just taking the five HTP?
Is that possible?
Because it seems like that might be the better move than to have to get a
prescription for some shit and like you'd get five HTP to fucking GNC store in
the middle of Omaha,
Nebraska,
just show up and get me and you can be on the road.
It's not like you're saddled down to a fucking pharmacy and you need to have
your doctor call in a prescription during business hours.
Well,
it's annoying.
Dr Pollinger study shows a lot of those ancillary benefits of,
you know,
not taking a prescription drug versus taking the natural drug and you can look
up,
does it have the same effect for everybody?
Five HTP for everybody boosts Serotonin?
It does,
yeah.
It definitely boosts search.
I mean,
how can you say something for everybody?
But in the people studied in the many studies that they've done,
five HTP has shown,
you know,
a dramatic improvement in those,
in those serotonin dependent,
um,
issues being,
and the new mood is mixed with fo,
uh,
El Tryptofan as well.
Yeah,
ultra map.
So the chain reaction goes l Tryptophan
converts to five HTP and then five HTP converts to five HTP,
five ht,
which is actually serotonin.
If you ingested pure five,
ht the body would destroy it and it wouldn't get anywhere.
But following it through the chain,
the body's able to do that.
Especially with the help of vitamin B six pyridoxine,
uh,
it's able to kind of complete that chain reaction of El Tryptophan to becoming
five HTP,
two becoming serotonin.
So new mood is pretty unique in that it has both El Tryptophan and five HTP as
well as the catalyst vitamin B six.
So,
um,
I'd love to study this in the future.
The theory behind it being that we're creating both in,
you know,
more immediate transition between the five HTP to five ht and then a longer term
transition between the l Tryptophan to the five HTP to the five ht.
So kind of providing a further spectrum along the chain.
And then we also combine it with a bunch of [inaudible] herbs,
herbs to kind of relax you and um,
you know,
help you help with insomnia.
One of our herbs,
Valerian actually has a similar study,
that study done by Dr Pollinger as comparing it to an over the counter and not
an over a prescription drug called [inaudible],
which is in the same category of a Benzo.
It's a Benzo,
it's same category as Xanax.
Um,
and it compared Valerian to Oxa possum with the similar results to the five HTP
study.
Being that Valerian had the same anxiety,
alytic insomnia reducing effects,
but without the negative side effects of that.
So that's another powerful herb and the combination and a few others as well,
just to kind of ease your body into a state of relaxation and positive
neurotransmitter boosting fundamentals.
A homeboy had another question and this was a,
the same dude,
this James Omega,
I think he had a really good point about,
he's saying that your claim was that,
uh,
Alpha brain enhances memory focus,
mental speed and mental drive.
Uh,
and he said,
can we meant,
can we rename mental drive to motivation?
First of all,
the,
you know,
mental drive was like,
God,
how subjective is that?
Like who can say what's,
you know,
how you're driven.
I mean,
even if it gives you like clarity,
does it actually drive you sort?
Right,
right.
Sure.
Um,
so he's saying,
would you say that those four are all of what Alpha brain is supposed to do is,
are other effects of which you want your product to claim than that?
Okay.
Then I'd like to hear them as well.
Right now he's Kinda being nit picky.
The
dream,
the dream effect is something that a lot of our,
our,
you know,
the takers really enjoy.
And that's caused by,
you know,
I think I mentioned this in the last time,
but that's caused by acetylcholine being the regulator of the rem state.
So with more Acetylcholine,
you have a deeper and broader rem state and rem being the dream state,
you're able to access longer periods of that dreaming unconsciousness for,
you know,
so to speak,
and also have more of a chance of turning those dreams lucid because of the
breadth of the dream state that you're in.
And also waking up during one of those states in which you will remember your
dreams a lot better than if you wake up during one of the really deep,
Slow Wave,
non dreaming sleeps.
This is theoretical or is it a sextant improving you can as far as waking up
during rem sleep drink,
they proven the dreams happen during rem state.
Right.
And that's what I mean.
And they've proven that when you wake up during rem sleep,
you're more likely to remember your dreams and when you wake up during slow
wave.
And how does the Acetylcholine play into that though?
Was it an improvement?
Has drink that's kind of your cycles are regulated by,
by the brain.
Unconsciously as it goes through.
And acetylcholine is they found one of the triggers for actually triggering the
Di,
you know,
slow wave versus a rem verses,
interphase one or two,
whatever,
whatever that is.
Acetylcholine is the trigger that actually triggers the length of rem sleep that
you have.
So if you have more acetylcholine available,
it's going to trigger a longer and deeper rem sleep.
Should you take Alpha brain at night to enhance your sleep.
Does that make sense or is it bullshit?
It was a lot of people say it makes them buzzy.
Yeah,
I wouldn't take it at night.
I don't think you need to take it at night.
I think if you take it during the day,
your levels are still going to be enhanced for for quite a while.
So I don't like to take it at night.
The latest I'll take it would be around three,
four o'clock because there is a kind of a stimulatory effect from the
Acetylcholine as well.
And Rm is not the deepest,
you know,
part of your sleep.
It's actually one of the lighter parts.
It's not.
So it will,
you know,
I do like to take it a little bit earlier.
I still get that dream kind of the wild dream boost where um,
you know,
like the other night where I was pulling a hammerhead shark out of a swimming
pool and doing a variety of different crazy things.
Um,
I still get that boost,
taking it early in the day and I think a lot of people will as well.
But um,
I would recommend that more than anything.
And then taking something like the new mood,
you would take that at night to kind of relax you and still make sure you're
getting the most out of the restorative parts of your sleep as well.
To me,
it seems like one of my dreams aren't so cool when I'm tired,
when I'm really beat down.
I've been doing a lot of traveling.
They don't,
they don't hit me with this big,
you know,
really a bizarre,
realistic style dreams.
But what I'm really well rested and I'm taking the Alpha and that's what I
noticed.
A really freaky fucking dreams.
Yeah,
that's what I like.
They're like,
they're like,
so there are so durable.
Like in the middle of the dream,
you wake up knowing that you're in the dream and somehow they're staying in the
dream.
Find that more when I'm well rested,
when I'm healthy,
I guess then you know,
you're,
you're calm or I guess I don't know what it do when you're drawing to that as
needy when you're sleeping,
your body might be pushing you into more deeper restorative kind of physically
restorative sleep.
When you're in that kind of run down state,
in which case you aren't having,
even with the Alpha brain present,
you aren't having that kind of length of rem and breadth of rem sleep.
So it was one of the things this guy is saying is,
uh,
sometimes,
justice a something I do know via my own studies in neuroscience,
the vast majority of people to not have a particular deficiency in
Acetylcholine,
dopamine or Gaba.
Well,
there's,
you know,
there's certainly different theories on that.
I mean,
I think,
uh,
in the optimal state of being with perfect diet,
perfect sleep,
you know,
good,
good health,
good workouts and all of that.
Probably your optimally functioning.
Um,
does that mean that you know,
going above optimal functioning is okay from time to time and actually has some
benefit and value?
I believe it does.
I believe you can,
even if you are naturally healthy at a baseline,
you know,
we're not kind of trying to cover deficiency,
we're not trying to cure disease,
we're trying to give people a feeling of boost that can help them,
you know,
function in maneuver and accomplish their goals,
whatever very they may be.
So,
you know,
I think that a,
I do think that norm,
a lot of people are a little bit run down and I know I rely on Dr Braverman of
the brain Princeton brain bio.
He did a lot of work there and he's doing a lot of active work now as the basis
for kind of my thinking on this.
But he did a bunch of tests on me and I'm a fairly healthy dude.
I eat well and I do my best to stay in shape.
But all of my levels of neurotransmitters were actually depressed below.
And before,
before I went to see him,
I had been doing a little,
you know,
doing a little party and he was in New York.
So I saw some buddies in New York went out to the bars.
And you know,
it made sense to me that my neurotransmitters were functioning at a lower level
at that point.
Cause I could feel it.
I was kind of cloudy,
kind of groggy.
And he pointed to that in all of the myriad tests he did.
We did tests over five days,
blood tests in different cognitive tests and different things.
Um,
and,
and found that,
and I think a lot of people operate on that.
You know,
just by the lifestyles that they live,
the operating this state where they're under a lot of stress and they're under a
lot of,
you know,
different,
uh,
you know,
different things like caffeine and alcohol and these things that are causing
adrenaline and different,
different functionality to happen so that there are more people who have at
least temporary deficiencies in a lot of these neurotransmitters.
And then for the people who don't,
you know,
getting this extra boost might just be a little bit over the top.
Well,
how many people actually get them,
get it actually tested.
That's why I get uncomfortable when someone says that the majority of people
don't have particularly deficiency and Acetylcholine,
the majority of people aren't tested for Acetylcholine deficiency.
Not and a lot of people,
a lot of people who,
if you could talk to them or anything,
the majority of people aren't tested for fucking vitamin B.
Yeah.
Tony Know How many people get blood work to check their vitamin levels.
How many people are,
you know,
very few actually with violence.
Isn't that the only way to tell it?
Is it,
is it actually
vitamin D?
They're finding massive deficiencies when they're actually doing large scale
testing on that.
So
it's very hard to tell someone saying that.
It's just a,
that's a bullshit thing to say.
Right,
right.
But there are certainly a lot of healthy people and,
and,
and you know,
they may have adequate levels,
but it's still doesn't invalidate the point of having an out for brain.
I do still do think that you can feel even better.
You know what I mean?
These are nutrients that are going to drive you in a certain direction.
So,
you know,
there's kind of both sides of the coin there,
I guess,
depending on how you look at it.
And here's the subtle yet conti last questions that he has.
I'm curious as to why it took so long to answer this question given that you
answered questions before.
And I asked this one quite like this before I ask this one on questions after
when it should be the easiest question for you to answer.
That's a Kentucky question,
sir.
That belays that exposes your,
your country nature.
That is a [inaudible] and his fucking photo of who is that
guy?
What's that guy's name?
The,
um,
the author?
No,
looks like Ben Stiller.
Sam a something or other,
um,
letters to a Christian nation.
What the fuck's the guy's name,
but he's got an intellectual,
you know,
I certainly,
I appreciate all the challenges that,
that people have.
I think it's,
you know,
it's good to think about all these things.
And I,
you know,
Sam,
as much criticism is as a,
I get personally on it gets,
I think ultimately if you take kind of,
you know,
what you may call the crunchiness out of it,
there's,
this is kind of like real reflection on yourself that you can take a gaze at.
It's like fighters who,
you know,
either you either train with people who all love you and care about you.
You go with savages that want to kill you and take your head off.
Well,
you'll learn more from the savages,
you know,
and you'll learn how to,
you learn different things about yourself,
holes in your game and weaknesses.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think actually you even talking to you,
it's not an easy thing to learn,
but learning to just take the meat of the criticisms and try and not take the,
uh,
the barbs of it.
So it's hard,
you know,
I know you kind of created a lot of what the website is,
but you know,
I go to the website and there's certain stuff.
I look,
I don't go,
it's a little fucking marketing,
you know,
it was a little,
you know what I mean?
I,
we'll,
we'll go over it.
We'll go over it because I don't personally think it needs to be that way.
I think the product stands on its own.
And I think the subject is very interesting.
And what I always tell people on the program as you just look into nootropics,
I mean,
this is one of the reasons why I wanted to have you,
uh,
address some of the shit that that's been said and um,
and let people know there's no evidence whatsoever that any of this stuff was
dangerous,
right?
No.
What happened to roll on and roll off what's been kind of
mood is taking,
he's taking over the rollover and it'd become a mess.
Another,
the partying aspect people don't have,
those are the origins of this,
of this,
uh,
experiment.
People for whatever reason have a,
you know,
if you,
you can't be a serious person.
So rollovers pretty much the shroom tech.
Uh,
no.
And then what's role on now anything Rolando Kinda got divided into two aspects
that it was trying to do too many things at once.
So the shroom tech sport provides that kind of energy element and then the
shroom tech immune provides the health element that was missed.
That was the second component.
So that's kind of been divided into two,
right?
Problem is,
um,
a lot of people automatically assume that people are full of shit.
And uh,
when you have any thing that they can criticize anything,
any,
any weakness in the link that they can point to and go,
oh,
he sells fucking Alpha nails.
Yeah.
Hey,
let me see your nails.
You doesn't have Alpha nails on.
Totally normal.
I mean,
come on man.
It's Alpha nails is like a Saturday night live sketch.
Well,
you know how that developed.
I was,
you know,
I was glad to,
fighters were a lot of fun and instill and I'm one of my best friends is Roger,
where today we are talking about it and all of these fighters still have to go
to that Sally Jensen Aisle in the supermarket and buy those dainty little nail
Polish
nail Polish.
They don't but,
but they,
but they can do it.
So they do
well there are some benefits.
Some of the fighters say that,
you know,
they put it on their toes because if they'd been stomped in the toe and their
nails gonna fall off,
it'll hide that potential damage.
Some people just say it and you know,
I don't know.
There's a few practical reasons also that it prevents chipping and kind of your
nail from breaking,
coming apart and having a tiny,
well it's kind of like putting a coat of glue over the top of your frank Trigg
started using and they used to call them twinkle toes trig because he would
paint up his nails like to protect the,
they can use clear coat,
but they don't use clear coat.
They use pink because why the fuck not because they're fighters in anybody who
says they're gay or not.
So,
uh,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's something that we kind of developed as a different alternative for that,
but it,
you know,
it's funny.
People will,
you know,
people get pretty,
pretty serious about,
uh,
about,
you know,
criticizing Islam variety.
There's some beautiful dopiness right here.
This is discontinuous,
his guys talking about a
Alpha brand.
He goes,
if you're under 35 and you take it,
you're effectively throwing,
you're perfectly balanced neurotransmitter levels out of balance.
Hmm.
I wonder if that's and capital the reason why some people say it makes them sick
or it doesn't work.
Ugh.
Just the sick typical business tactics that virtually everyone in the industry
uses.
Like you dumb fuck,
are you not listening to any of this?
You fucking shithead.
There's some people it can benefit stupid and if you don't like it,
you don't have to focus on it.
If it's not your thing,
you don't have to get into it.
But people are looking for something to point a finger on.
Sure.
There's a lot of people out there that are looking to be empowered by
criticizing the,
it'd be be empowered by pointing a finger if you don't like it,
don't buy it stupid.
And if you're under 35 and you take it,
oh cause you've done extensive studies,
you know the exact time when people need it.
Shut up.
Stupid.
You just being a cunt.
Yeah.
I was
well under 35 when I was studied and certainly not a,
not a large candidate for it and I was shown to be deficient in a variety of
these neurotransmitters and I was um,
I promise I was,
you know,
as,
as healthy or healthier than a good amount of people.
So will we ever see on it in stores like absolutely.
We're working on trying to get my dad on.
Yeah.
We'll send it to him man and sell it to him.
I meant to send it to them.
[inaudible] dad's money,
Bro.
Come on Daddy.
They'll always be the advantage of buying it directly from us because we'll be
able to honor that money back guarantee that it will be up to the stores if you
buy it in the stores.
But um,
you need to get that on Amazon,
man.
Amazon's just so easy nowadays.
Just like with food items on,
if any of the grocery items you can have it.
So it's sets every month just to automatically send you certain items.
Like I do it with coconut
water and stuff like that.
It's so nice.
It's like
gifts every Joe,
I'm sorry,
what Brian,
is that you?
Are you there
anyway?
We want to talk about nothing.
Okay guys,
I've got to fucking,
I got a message board filled with idiots.
Why?
I think barring other comedians jokes onstage.
Okay,
I should pick this guy just cause it's so fucking stupid either.
He's trolling.
First of all I know's will be controversial,
but hear me out.
I think it's okay to borrow other comedians material we could stand up.
Comedy is a performance art.
They does it in all caps.
Why is it when idiots want to make a point and they think it's profound.
They put it in all caps.
Oh it's a performance art.
Shut up.
Stupid.
It's dealing joke that simple.
He's got a thing about Dennis leery about talking about.
Great Dennis.
Hilarious.
I could hardly handle your message board and mark as currently hat waiter
anymore.
Some girl the other day on our guy on Twitter the other day ask my girlfriend if
she would like to be kidnapped and raped for a couple of days.
But what do you think bro?
You put it out there in the podcast.
What to expect.
No,
no,
no.
This is a guy that doesn't know about me or anything.
This is just a creepy gag cause he does it to a lot of girls and they look at,
you look at his Twitter and he's just like this angry.
You're like,
man,
what if I'd fought for a chick to say,
yeah come come fuck raped the shit out of me son.
I don't know.
I almost wonder like would it be cool to like have like your own Internet?
Like like it's a friends list of your Internet.
So like everything,
well that's sort of what it is on Twitter.
You know when you block somebody's,
you know you find shit has you block them.
That's sort of what it is.
The message board when Shit heads pop up you block them.
You know what bothers me man,
is just the numbers on the message board or are so great at this point,
right?
It's like it's gotten to such a crazy point where there's,
there's over 6 million posts on this fucking bored,
you know,
or 5 million,
798,000 that's crazy.
So many people,
it's so hard to keep track of it but it's so,
it's so hard to,
which you got to do is just weed out the cons when you find weeds and your
grass,
just pull them out and pluck them.
But there's so many of them and there's so many trolls are so many people that
are just doing it for reactions.
Even my friends like a non,
he just,
he trolls all the time and I just look at this,
the arguments that he presents and they're just so ridiculous.
But then he'll be a fucking 30 page argument,
you know,
30 pages of people biting his troll and then he
on it.
It's a waste.
It's sort of,
but it's a,
it's a massive waste.
Maybe we should have an old truck,
no trolls zone where you're not allowed to troll like one,
but it's also an intelligence test.
A lot of people,
cause some trolls are so fucking obvious when people were jumping on him and
you're like,
God really like the one with the guy who just,
we talked about a comedian stealing.
He's either reason idiot or that's a successful troll.
You've got us to talk about it,
right?
You know,
people love that for whatever fucking reason.
All these dingbats out there love just getting someone's reaction when you
respond to that,
it gives a win.
Like what a weird way to win.
Just a massively annoying con until someone calls you out on it and then you go
poned,
what is that?
A ridiculous game you're playing where it's impossible for you lose.
All you have to do is just be really annoying until someone calls you on it and
then you're a winner.
Like what to talk about setting the bar low man.
I mean,
is that like the lowest bar ever?
All you have to do is be enough of a shithead that somebody points it out and
then you're a winner.
Everybody's going to have to be their own fucking name soon that's going to fix
everything.
And it's one of the things with Twitter that somebody pointed out that's a
really good point.
He said,
most people on Twitter,
it's,
you know,
I look at your fucking name,
boom,
there's your name.
You know,
most people have Joshua Blah,
blah,
blah.
They have their fucking name on their Twitter page.
Somehow Facebook just added my fucking phone number on.
I didn't eat,
I didn't put my phone number on my Facebook and the other day somebody was like,
why do you have your real phone?
Like real phone number on your Facebook page?
And I'm like,
are you fucking serious?
And it's like my app or my iPhone must have done it or something.
Wow.
You might want to check that shit man.
Cause I didn't do it and
yeah,
I don't have my phone on anything.
That's ridiculous though.
And then like this Twitter shit,
like uh,
the location it's set to default on the other day and I'm like great.
I just told everybody where I live.
You don't remember I got,
I got hacked,
my Twitter got hacked and they were saying something about it.
I'll join a contest and win an iPad too.
They've got lady Gaga,
Lady Gaga.
I sent out a tweet to like 100 million people.
Whoever the fuck she's gotten her Twitter page about an iPad too.
Wow.
Cause apparently lady Gaga does her own Twitter and everybody likes to know
that,
which I do too.
I'm not comparing myself to lady Gaga.
No one can compare to Gaga.
Uh,
you know,
they can do that somehow or another,
they get into your account.
Like if you,
I dunno what what you have to do,
but there must be some legal way they're doing it because it can be as simple as
they get your password because they don't seem to be sending a bunch of other
shit out with it.
It's just as one tweet that keeps repeating about,
you know,
sign up for an iPad too.
That seems to be the one that everybody gets gangs.
Well that's a money market money.
The most machines pointed at hacking.
How do they do that?
How are they getting,
are they getting your password generators?
Is that what we're running full time board generators and you click on a link in
it,
you're not logged in and you log in by mistake.
Someone hits you with like a keystroke tracker or some other more devious virus
like that.
But usually it's just kind of password generators.
Complicated passwords are important.
Are those that a common keystroke generators like uh,
like is that what happens?
Like,
say if someone,
if you get a virus,
Dale w w what will happen is like if you go to somewhere and use a credit card,
it'll like store that.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It records everything you do kind of like that.
That shit.
Yeah.
Iq,
client,
whatever it was.
Yeah.
Have you seen that shit?
It's the,
is they found out there was some sort of a,
what does it Iq?
Is that what it is?
I CQ Kleiner game.
Um,
there was a,
um,
a program that they found running in the background of droids that was storing
every single stroke that you made,
every number that you dialed every word that you sent a text message and sending
it to a database somewhere.
Yeah.
And there's some giant class action lawsuit.
Matt.
It's nuts,
man.
You gotta be,
you gotta Watch out for these different things as technology expands,
but I dunno,
it's difficult to fight.
Yeah.
Except you have to at least be in it a little.
I was talking to my sister yesterday cause she's like,
should I get an iPhone?
I'm like,
yeah,
it's just got an iPhone.
They're like,
well t mobile is saying I could have this free my touch three or whatever.
My seriously get off of t mobile,
go to Verizon,
get an iPhone,
whatever.
She's like,
are you sure?
And then she's like asking me these other questions about tech,
but some technology people love droids zone.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
But uh,
but she was asking me these other questions of technology and around her house
does,
she goes,
how much would I have paid just to get Wifi in my house?
Is it like 70 $80?
I'm like,
what?
And she's like,
she said she thought you had to pay $80 a month just for Wifi.
And so I had to explain to her like how no Wifi is just a box that hooks up to
your Internet that you already have and then you can use.
If so for what?
10 years?
She hasn't had wifi cause she thought it was like 70 bucks a month.
Why didn't she ask them?
Why they don't know?
I,
I dunno man.
That's just the thing on your sister.
I don't think you'd use it,
but there's a lot of people that are like that,
that,
yeah.
Refused to.
And my sister's younger than me and I'm like,
he should be more of a computer to the shit.
Yeah,
totally out of it that she has on a smartphone.
She's still on a flip phone,
you know?
Wow.
And it's just like,
come on,
you're,
you're a younger girl.
Some people don't want anymore
distractions in their lives.
Didn't want to be able to watch TV on their phone.
Right.
For some people it's porn.
There's some dudes have a problem with porn on their phone.
I was reading about this,
like guys have like fucking gigs of porn on their phone as her house porn on
their phone.
Really?
She used to sometimes like someone that's grocery wants a girl,
especially the little one like Esther just thinking about are just shoving
things in there.
So as we bring this fucking odd podcast home,
we never really did figure out a way to fix this situation,
but we can drive it around it and we just did it.
We gave it,
we gave it the date that's looking around.
What a fucking to take care of it.
Yeah.
Well I think the number one thing that's going to happen at some of the people
that are in power,
I have to slowly die off.
They have to get old and pass on and then the young people have to move into a
position of power where they kind of grow up with the Internet and they grow up
with a better understanding of how they're perceived and how the world works and
how things don't have to be as greedy and fucked up and corrupt as they are.
Halliburton didn't have to make that much money and Ron didn't have to make that
much money.
You know,
so much of what happened didn't have to happen.
So much of the money that changed,
changed hands and you know,
so much of the transactions that transpire,
they weren't necessarily like it got too crazy.
You know?
And I think the upcoming generations will see that that will be
historically,
I think we're seeing it now.
And I think that,
you know,
this talk of the return,
it cuts a quad,
all the new type of that that's going to change things.
I think really what that may be is just the movement.
And I think we're all part of that.
That kinda new person that's arriving,
that new consciousness that's creating itself.
And I think there will be leaders that will emerge from that movement.
But the movement itself is what's key.
And I think all of us who are playing are,
are part kind of expanding.
You know,
what we're open to and our beliefs and both riding that balance between
skepticism and an open mind,
you know,
have to be,
you have to have both and you have to have,
have that kind of truth seeking aspect of yourself to doe,
you know,
find the ways between that silage or absurdness of,
of the skepticism and the,
you know,
to open in [inaudible] and,
and find where the truth lies.
And I think that's uh,
that's going to be the key key trade of what we need to do here going forward.
And that's going to create the movement that will inspire the leaders.
I just hope it stays together in some form.
I hope we don't have to rebuild civilization cause that would fucking suck cause
I live around too many dummies.
You know,
there's just too many dummies out there to just rely on the people that are at
hand right now and I have some sort of an even vote and have everything work.
Right.
Yeah.
It's just,
we're not prepared but like little children toss into the woods,
right?
Yeah.
Well we're not prepared to be running shit.
God dammit heats.
Keep it together.
To a certain extent people would be,
it would be better than severe.
We don't,
we don't need anything fucking traumatic.
The more we do preemptive,
I really like the more you go out there and push aggressively now the better
that's going to be.
If we just kind of let things happen that's no ball comes crashing hard.
But if we're out there pushing it now,
like,
like we're doing here on the podcast player in our small part,
everybody else play in their small part to open their consciousness,
open their friends consciousness and find that truth,
then uh,
you know,
hopefully it'll fall a little less hard when it actually comes to crash.
Listen Arbor,
you got a lot of haters on my message board.
One of the reasons is because you change your fucking name to Aubrey.
The other is because you're a little bit too handsome and do's don't like that.
It makes them uncomfortable then then all of the marketing stuff.
But people always ask me,
why am I involved with you?
Why am I involved with this?
Cause I know you and I know you're really good,
dude,
you're a hundred percent legit.
And this,
the reason why I'm involved with you is because you're that guy.
You're 100%,
you're legit.
You're,
you know,
a lot of people were skeptical and I totally understand that.
I give you the stamp,
I'll give you a stamp of approval.
You're an exceptional human being,
and I appreciate every time we talk in the podcast.
I enjoy the fuck out of it.
I enjoy hanging out with you.
It's always cool.
Thank you to everybody for tuning in.
We appreciate you.
Even the fucking haters,
as we said,
without you,
we would not have that harsh,
brutal criticism that sometimes makes you really see things from a different
perspective.
Uh,
thank you to the fleshlight.
if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter
it,
the code name Rogan,
you will get percent off and yes,
you will shoot your loads at a discount.
It's a fine product.
Plays a gentleman dub the scared.
Go out and get some.
It's legit.
I know you're going to masturbate.
You know,
you know,
you got to masturbate.
I didn't say that that smoothly,
but we know what the fuck.
I'm fine.
Thank you to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N,
n.
I.
T if you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on that link for Alpha brain entering the code name brogue and get 10%
off.
Or don't do not understand.
Our life is not dependent on you following that.
You don't have to listen to me.
Don't get crazy though.
Don't get upset.
Settle down.
Um,
if you're interested in nootropics,
please Google them.
Read up on them.
Educate yourself.
If you can't afford what we're selling,
but you're interested by the shit and you know on bulk and make your own copy
our formula,
we really don't care.
And if you don't like it and you buy it from us,
you get a hundred percent money back guarantee.
We can't make it easier,
bitches.
It's impossible to make it easier to focus.
I'm trying to make it as easy as possible.
You fuck settle down.
Keep it together.
Pitches.
We're all in this together and shit has just started to get strange ice house
this Friday,
the 23rd,
right?
We're doing a show and this will be our second anniversary.
We are number one in the comedy section of iTunes right now.
Praise Odin.
Thank you to everybody who tunes in and you know the,
the thing about the iTunes that's the most satisfying,
so satisfying to us and said,
everybody told us that,
you know,
you shouldn't have your shit on Stitcher,
you shouldn't have your shit on Ustream,
you shouldn't have your shit on Vimeo because then it'll affect your iTunes
numbers.
The fact that we have,
uh,
the number one podcast in the comedy section of iTunes on top of all that other
stuff that we do,
having it out there in the APP,
having it as an RSS feed just means that you guys are enjoying it and that means
the fucking world to me and I could not be happier.
We'd love doing it.
We're never going to stop doing it and we're never going to start charging money
for it.
It's always going to be free.
Thank you bitches.
We love you and we'll see you soon.
Listen to the Josh gross a interview and people had to have a note that she had
Josh growth.
Is that his name?
He has.
We just released that episode yesterday on the Death Squad layer,
which is very little bit.
Yeah.
We talked to him a little bit about,
uh,
how he can't say that he smokes weed and how he can't,
that he fucked up when he released the information for the ultimate fighter.
Right.
You know,
which I think is,
I think that's just stupid.
I mean like,
like I,
I agreed that's a spoiler,
but that's like going,
hey Bambi,
his mom died.
You know,
and that's,
come on,
don't be like,
yeah,
there's a fine line between a journalist and a spoiler.
I don't,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
I,
I see where his point of view is.
I disagree with it though.
It's as far as that goes.
I don't want to know the fucking results.
Like I told you,
I could find out who won.
I can find out one every season.
I W I go through the whole process like everybody else does.
You sneak peek and bitches.
All right.
This podcast is fucking over.
Thank you very much.
We already did that.
Yeah,
we did it.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
I thought her Donna.
Oh,
we did it.
Both of them,
Bro.
You're out of it,
man.
You
need some brain needs.
Some memory.
Fucking electrodes are so some shock therapy.
I've been eating my flashlights and fucking lamp for brains by mistake.
Oh one one notification for those who couldn't get the product in in Europe were
coming up with a formula that's going to be able to cross all the,
all the different borders.
What is the hold up in Europe?
Different random things.
Although some of it's even vitamin B six is illegal and a in a couple of places.
Ireland.
Yeah.
Pirate vitamin B six they don't want to healthy.
They want to keep going a doc and fucking pay it and angry and drunk and fucking
fucking asshole.
Thank you very much.
That was the worst Irish accent I think I've ever done.
But we'll have,
we'll have something out here for you.
Partial Gaelic.
And there was a little Australian thrown in there.
It's fucking shows over.
Good night.
Good night everybody.
Bye.
Love Ya.
So yeah,
see you soon.
Bye everybody.
Much level.